[Music]
[Music]
i welcome all those who have just joined
we would be starting in more 10 minutes
we are waiting for the others to join as
well
yes nassar you will have the session
recordings we'll share the recordings
with you over mail as well and also you
can find the recordings on youtube we
are streaming live you can have a like
just paste the link of the youtube with
uh
in your chat box or in your
note notepad maybe and you can refer it
in future yes
and by the way the zoom link and the
youtube link would be the same for the
whole day so you need not worry
so in sr we have a criteria for the
certification my
uh team members will let you know you
need to register yourself on the omics
research symposium registration page in
order to get the certificate because
it's not possible for us to keep a note
on who all is joining where zoom so
please fill out the registration form
we'll share the details with you please
drop your main id here or our uh or my
team member who just and navia will
tell you the criteria please register
yourself so that we have your
registration and then we'll send the
certificate thank you
[Music]
i welcome all those who have just joined
we would be starting in five more
minutes thank you for joining
thank you everyone for waiting so
patiently
we will be starting in few minutes
giving in time to others to join as well
hello and welcome to the second day of
omics research symposium this two-day
event is designed to bring together
students researchers faculty and
industry to discuss recent advances in
omics data technologies and analysis
in this symposium we will discuss the
changing role of bioinformatics we will
learn about exciting projects in
academia and industry such as clinical
pharma biotech research and even
agriculture
as a result you will learn about
exciting projects in academia and
industry where data analysis skills and
solutions are urgently needed the
symposium discussion will be accompanied
by a poster session and competition
awarding prizes and giving a stage to
students faculty and research teams to
present their work and get expert
feedback you will also get a glimpse of
international community working together
to advance bioinformatics education
around the world to make this field more
accessible to anyone
it has now become increasingly clear
that there is a huge demand in
bioinformatics training which has led to
the establishment of omix logic
bioinformatics training programs with
thousands of participants tens of
university programs and local chapters
in asia africa and the america where
dedicated teams interact with students
and faculty we will also hear from these
teams about their achievements and
vision as the program continues to grow
as the pandemic continues to keep us
safely at home we hope that we can make
the most from this virtual experience i
am sure there will be some technical
glitches and the interaction will be
very different from attending in person
and that is why i would like to start by
addressing some common questions at the
start of this program you will find all
the important information about the
speakers their talks and the schedule on
a symposium
schedule page the same website contains
other information on poster competition
zoom links and panels where we will be
able to ask experts about their thoughts
on the topics we discussed today use the
chat box at the bottom right corner of
the screen to submit your questions for
panelists or get in touch with our team
for any other questions you might have
we will also invite you to review and
share the content you will see here on
social media you can connect with us on
linkedin slack or facebook my team
members will be sharing the link with
you all in the chat box you can also
find us on the other social media
platforms where we will be sharing
updates insights from the symposium and
also introduce our speakers but let us
focus now on the reason we are all here
today this second day of the symposium
is dedicated to how can we get involved
and make an impact in data and life
sciences
so to introduce that i would now like to
invite mr ilya brodsky mr eric brodsky
is one of the co-founder and ceo of pine
biotech he has facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams as well mr ilya brodsky oversees
the research projects and manages the
development of the prototype preparation
of the relevant data projects and
implementation of the system for the
need of students and teachers that the
project is designed for over to you mr
elia
thank you so much and before we begin
maybe we could launch the poll
you will launch the ball
uh yes just a second elia uh can you
just launch the poll after your talk
okay
it's asking me to sign in i'm not
signing from the official account i
think
okay
all right thank you everyone and great
to be here today
and then you thank you sonalika for uh
the introduction
um so i'm excited to be here on our
second day
um and as soon alik already mentioned uh
we will go on to speak about how what
one can get involved in bioinformatics
in a more serious way to contribute to
the field as it becomes more dynamic
more impactful
with many real and important
applications across many domains in life
science research and industry
and
before
we begin i want to briefly
share an overview of what we covered
last
day in multiple sessions that we had
we had a lot of great speakers
panel discussions uh project
presentations so it was a really
exciting opportunity to be together for
all of us
so first of all we heard about the omics
logic programs in india
uh india is one of the most populous
countries in the world
and is a growing economy that is
producing millions of graduates every
year
overall india has over 1 000
universities with 42 000 colleges and
over 11 000 standalone institutions in
the country that is catering to over 38
million students and so what our team is
doing is working there since 2019
partnering with institutions in the
country
and
addressing some of the gaps in
bioinformatics education by offering
research opportunities to students that
are working with faculty on various data
science projects across many life
science domains and building a pathway
for students to work in biotechnology
pharma and bioinformatic industries
and
after working with thousands of students
from around the country our team shared
lessons learned and offered an important
perspective moving forward with some new
initiatives that have undergone major
changes as a result of this pandemic
one key insight
actually came out of the panel
discussion
where we heard about the challenges and
opportunities in bioinformatics in india
so we heard from dr raghav and professor
radana that offered their insights in
academic research as well as government
initiatives and urgent need for data
science in healthcare and biotechnology
industry in india
we also heard from our team in africa
where amex logic training has been
launched in 2019
sub-saharan africa is home to more than
one billion people
half of whom will be under the age of 25
by 2050 so it is a very diverse
continent that offers a lot of human and
natural resources
and they have the potential to yield
inclusive growth and
importantly eradicate some of the
challenges including
poverty and
various types of infectious diseases
and so what we heard was
about how
uh many of those
areas of research are being addressed
using bioinformatics
we heard from dr anita ganza from ghana
dr vokitori from nigeria dr adrian lusa
from south africa and some of our team
members mr adela
and mr hamza that have worked with
numerous students in this region
overall it was an insightful day where
we got a global perspective so i want to
thank all of the speakers who have
shared their perspective on what going
what was going on in africa and india
and here are some of my personal
takeaways so first of all there is a
pressing need to review annotate and
improve data quality the both the data
that is currently available and some of
the future data sets that will be shared
we heard from dr raghav how his
group of students and himself are
working to make that process more
effective and offer a lot of resources
for those learning bioinformatics
we heard about the urgent need of
training in bioinformatics and data
science for those who are working on
important challenges in medicine public
health and other domains
we heard about bridge programs that
connect students with authentic research
opportunities and with industry careers
and hello we've heard about some of the
exciting opportunities for students and
researchers to be involved in many
fields of research working together with
mentors and leaders in these fields
after that we heard about some of the
exciting developments in the world of
bioinformatics research and applications
to various challenges like byron
that's the last
uh yes sorry i had to
mute all the particip
okay
thank you
sorry about that so we heard about
some of the speakers that are working on
bioinformatics and developing new
approaches that are used by thousands of
researchers and students and so here are
my takeaways from those talks
first of all there's a growing
complexity of omics data including
single cell
okay including single cell sequencing
large scale genomic whole genome
sequencing data and important questions
about the junk
non-coding sequences or the dark part of
the genome where important regulatory
elements are being defined
we heard about
we heard about experimental data that
can reveal a snapshot of biological
activity but to see the whole picture
there's the need for integration of
multi-omics data
time estimation and mathematical models
that can be simulated to understand what
these biological snapshots can tell us
about trajectories and time
we also heard about the way this
pandemic has spurred active research in
many areas leading to new approaches for
genomic surveillance
novel types of vaccines and even new
interventions based on our understanding
of viral
evolution and finally we heard about a
new or maybe an old field called
astrobiology
first of all we heard about how it has
contributed to the development of
genomic technologies in general and what
data sets are available
and heard about some of the novel
findings coming from the study of
extremophiles that are useful
on
on her on here on earth with many
applications in biotechnology
and these talks were accompanied with a
panel discussion on the topic of omics
data and associated methods of analysis
so we heard about uh the perspectives uh
on how this field of bioinformatics is
playing a major role in various research
projects from dr raul endino from the
university of california san francisco
uh dr sona vasudevan from georgetown
university who's also going to be
speaking today we heard about dr lena
brodsky from the talbot bioinformatics
research center
at the university of haifa and dr
kusulus from the national association of
idea principal investigators he also
will be speaking today
and finally
we heard from dr laura harris from
michigan state university so what these
speakers highlighted was the role that
the students can play
and some opportunities for early career
scientists in many areas including
virology microbiology biotechnology and
as well as clinical and biomedical
research projects to utilize
bioinformatics and get involved in many
other projects so briefly um
i want to tell you uh what is the reason
that we are organizing this symposium
and how can we transition from some of
the topics that we heard about yesterday
and go on to the topic of today's
sessions so the onyx logic programs
which are operated by pine biotech
are designed to provide training and
bioinformatics that enable independent
research guided by mentors and peer
example
it is also to develop a growing
community that shares a passion for
data-driven research and many
applications of citizen science so it is
really a goal of ours to build this
community and part of that process is
this symposium and ultimately our goal
is to enable students clinicians and
faculty of all backgrounds to develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences and so the way that we do this
is by offering training programs that
provide access to high performance
computing mentorship and training in
bioinformatics and data science for
biological data
the training modules are offered through
the omixlogic portal where you can
register for free and explore
asynchronous modules on various types of
rmix data exercises in pipeline building
coding in r and python as well as offer
a view of case studies based on
peer-reviewed publications from top
research journals
so the link and to the portal that you
can explore today as well
is right here
what these projects are organized into
learning paths for oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience and agriculture in
each learning path we use examples that
illustrate major trends and novel
applications of omics data in particular
field and since the domain of
bioinformatics is so dynamic we are
relying on collaborators in all of these
fields to navigate updated topics and
developments
we work closely with our partners at the
tauber bioinformatics research center
where the team is making many algorithms
for data analysis easy to use for
non-bioinformaticians using the t-biome
for platform which offers a
user-friendly interface for many
commonly used methods on phylodynamics
analysis of gene expression alignment to
reference genomes analysis of structural
data and variant calling and so this tbi
info platform is also available um on
this link
um okay sorry about that
there we go
so one of our programs that we
highlighted throughout the symposium is
the research fellowship where students
can design an independent research
project and work in groups with mentors
that guide them to complete their
research using bioinformatics relying on
publicly available data sets and working
with mentors that are provided through
our program and through our network
many of the research fellows have been
working for the past several months to
complete their projects and share them
for the poster session that you see
today
you will find the projects that they
have submitted organized on this link so
please naviance we post a link to the
poster presentations
where we are also
expecting feedback from the judges as
well as all of the other participants so
you can all go
to this page and actually um thank you
jaspy and actually see all of the
posters and also contribute your
feedback as well as other participants
of this
symposium
so briefly let me introduce kind of an
overview for the plan for this day so
the main goal of this day is to
introduce you to some of the ways that
you can continue your journey into the
field of bioinformatics
joining degree awarding academic
programs which we will hear about today
for bioinformatics and also thinking
about your career in either academic
research or industry so we'll hear from
some panelists that will describe what
does it take to go from academia to
industry and what are some of the
opportunities there
so first of all we will talk about uh
the some of the programs uh so we will
hear from professor sima bhatnagar
who has a history of research in
medicinal medicinal chemistry and is
working with the higher education
and she is skilled in organic synthesis
drug discovery drug design protein
chemistry and biochemistry and she will
speak about
the program at amity university
we will also hear from
dr sona vasudevan who is the director
for systems medicine program at
georgetown university medical center in
washington dc in the us
we will hear from dr philip campo who is
an associate teaching
professor and assistant department head
in the computational biology department
at carnegie mellon university
he's a passionate educator who has
taught a range of stem courses to a
diverse uh group of students
and he is an experienced administrator
who is working
on this program at carnegie mellon
we'll also heard from uh we'll hear from
dr casulis who is a professor of
virology and biotechnology in the
department of pathobiological sciences
and the director of the division of
biotechnology and molecular medicine or
biomed
he is also the director of the
nih-funded center for experimental
infectious disease research and the
director of the nih-funded louisiana
biomedical research network molecular
and cell biology core and and the
president of the national association of
idea principle investigators
we will hear from dr chindo hicks who is
a program director for a bioinformatics
research program with a focus on health
and health disparities including their
research and some of the academic
awarding degrees that they offer
we will also hear from dr chris taylor
who is a researcher
focused on computational biology and
bioinformatics and especially in the
applications of high throughput
sequencing for microbiology
we will finally hear a presentation by
dr shamir khadr who is a senior director
of advanced analytics data science and
bioinformatics at astrazeneca
and is leading
a global team of data scientists
biomedical scientists statisticians and
software engineers to address some of
the
pharma-oriented challenges in this field
so and finally we will conclude with a
panel that i'm very excited to hear from
all of the speakers where we will hear
from dr shamier khadr
tarun walia
as well as sorry anthony
finlow from
eagle genomics and i see that there's a
mistake on the slide but we will correct
that and they will speak about some of
the ways that
you know you can get involved as a
student as an early career scientist in
this field in the field of
bioinformatics where are the different
opportunities and what are some of the
challenges between academic and industry
approaches to bioinformatics so finally
all of the poster presentations are
going to receive feedback from some of
the judges
we have an excellent panel of judges dr
sono vasudevan chris taylor philip campo
julia panov
g payano chavez abhishek singh gupta and
dr habrika or so they will all provide
you with feedback on the posters um
here from our team will be monitoring
the chats as if you have any questions
or just via navi i see there is a
question already and before we jump to
our first speaker
i would like to ask sonalika to launch
the poll to kind of get a sense of um
who is participating today with us
so sonalika could you
launch the poll
yes
thank you so much so i have three
questions my first question is what is
your educational background are you a
graduate or a post post graduate from
phd or postdoc what is your designation
student faculty researcher or are you
from the administration and management
and what are your research interests is
it infectious diseases data science
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics or r or pythons for
bioinformatics or precision medicine
okay so you launched the call
yes it's launched earlier
i can see that 40 percent of the
participants have voted uh and i would
be keeping the poll on for more 30
seconds
it would be great if you could all
please vote so that we know from what
our backgrounds you are
okay
and
um
as we wrap that up
mohit and would you be able to introduce
our speaker professor seema bhatnagar
here
[Music]
short journey and looking forward to all
the upcoming sessions and uh it's an
absolute pleasure to introduce
professors
who is an assistant director at mit uh
institute of biotechnology at the
university of noida
professor sima batnagar is also an
experienced professor with a
demonstrated history of research in
medicinal chemistry and working in
higher educational industry professor
bhatnagar has been associated with
research and development in the field of
drug recovery and working with various
organized government and non-government
organizations before her current
assignment with
[Music]
okay sorry it sounds like maybe mohit
had some difficulties in connecting
but professor
sima it's great to see you here
and uh please share your screen
so we can all see your presentation
thank you alien
[Music]
sorry
am i out of it
yes yes but i
i think uh yes so dr uh nagar is sharing
her screen already so we can let her
continue so are my slides visible
yes
okay
thank you
so uh good evening everyone from india
uh i'm professor dr sima patnagar
assistant director at amity institute of
biotechnology and today i am here to
talk about a folate receptor a rational
therapeutic target for cancer treatment
this is the area in which i am working
and i will also be speaking a bit about
the programs at amity
as per session schedule
so cancer as we know is becoming a
global
epidemic and
we are seeing more and more cancer cases
it is estimated that
one in five people will be
suffering from cancer in coming years
and this includes one in eight men
and one in eight females will also
succumb to the disease so this is
something really alarming and something
that requires immediate attention and uh
so so that is what is the focus of my
talk today
we are also seeing that
in middle and
[Music]
medium and low income countries
there will be a steep rise in the cancer
cases
as predicted by by 2040
as compared to the countries where
already there are more cases but in in
future we will see more cases in
countries which are of low and medium
income
so india falls in that category and
that's why this is a matter of concern
to everyone
[Music]
if we talk of the cancer mortality the
situation is uh
[Music]
alarming as well
so uh if you see the
gender divide
males and females equally are
equally prone to the disease and we are
seeing a high mortality of the disease
both in males and females
and india has a high mortality rate
so historically if we look at
the drugs or the chemotherapeutic agents
which are which were available
for treatment of cancer we see that
the first attempts to look at
chemotherapeutic agents started
somewhere in the late 1940s
and truly the decade between 1960 to
1970 can be called as the decade of
adjuvant chemotherapy where a number of
agents were
not only discovered but they were also
tested and
many of them were from plant sources and
they are still in use today however
they have a number of drawbacks and that
is the reason for the
growing concern about
how we can improve the quality of life
of individuals and how we can prevent
the disease or if not preventable at
least treat them and
improve the quality of life of cancer
patients
the last 20 years from the year 2000
has seen a large number of small
molecules that are coming up for
targeted cancer therapy there are a
number of targets that have been
explored and small molecules that target
these
receptors
or pathways in
for cancer
have shown a lot of promise however
if we look uh in terms of the experience
of patients
we don't see much
improvement and according to the world
world health organization
every year in india at least 10
10 lakh individuals
suffer from the disease and the spending
in a cancer
suffering
household is at least 36 to 44
higher than as compared to households of
similar demographics even the cost of
treatment has gone up so what is really
wrong are we not having drugs or if
you're having drugs then why are we not
able to reduce the cost and what is the
way to improve the quality of life of
individuals who
suffer from the disease so this is uh
something that
that needs to be looked into
so all this has given
initially there was the focus was on
traditional medicine which included
radiation chemotherapy and surgery but
now this has given way to more targeted
therapies the involvement of genetics of
individuals and also immunotherapy
for treatment of the disease
[Music]
so so our group at amity is involved in
study of the folate receptor and we are
looking into
new drug delivery options uh how we can
deliver low concentration of the drug to
the cancer cells in a targeted way
and the folate receptor appears as a
very attractive target
for cancer drug delivery the reason
being that
first of all it has been newly
identified and
there are three isoforms of the folate
receptor the folate receptor alpha beta
and gamma however the folate receptor
alpha
has uh has seen a lot of success and
promising therapeutic target in a
variety of cancers um non-malignant
tissues um express very limited amount
of folate receptor alpha whereas uh
the
malignant tissues and especially solid
tumors uh the ovarian cancer kidney lung
brain
breast cancer
lung cancer and you name it all these
have
over expression of
the folate receptor
also what is important is that folate
the folate receptor alpha has high
affinity for folic acid and conjugates
of folic acid can be considered as good
um
opportunities to target the cancer cells
and a number of clinical trials are also
ongoing in this area
so
i will spend some time uh talking about
the accessibility of the cellular uptake
through the folate receptor we know that
80 percent of the human cancers are
derived from epithelial cells and those
receptors that are restricted to the
apical regions of the cells
can be considered as good targets
because uh when drugs are administered
parentally
they are not
accessible to normal cells and this is a
big advantage because most of the drugs
that were already available they lack
selectivity especially the
chemotherapeutic drugs they lack
selectivity they show a lot of toxicity
because they not only target
the cancer cells they also target the
normal cells so if you are using a
targeted approach then obviously you
will be able to
take care of
the off target toxicity which is seen in
most cases
so
since receptors are epically expressed
so when the drug is administered
parentally it is not accessible to the
to the normal cells however when the
cells become malignant and the tight
junctions collapse in those cases the
folate receptor becomes redistributed
on the cell membrane and that is the
reason why it becomes accessible to
drug conjugates which may be uh
administered parentally so this is a big
advantage that
where you can opt for targeted drug
delivery
so
three general
strategies have been
explored
we have anti-folate receptor antibody
approach the humanized folate receptor
alpha
antibody drug conjugate approach and the
folic acid smdc approach smdc is the
small molecule drug conjugate approach
so if you look at the molecule of folic
acid
it comprises of three regions you have
the teradine ring you have the para
aminobenzoic
acid
portion of the molecule and you have the
glutamic acid
so it is the pterydine ring which is
primarily involved in the binding to the
folate receptor therefore this part of
the molecule is very much available for
functionalization and can be used
for drug delivery
so a couple of drugs just as examples uh
so here we have the antibody approach
where pharmacism has been
has been tested not only in phase two
but also in phase three and
what has been seen so far is that it did
not meet the primary endpoint of
improving progression-free survival in
patients
we
there are also some studies which show
um the antibody drug conjugate approach
and milf is one such molecule
one such agent which has been tested
and it is showing some promise but uh
still in phase one and phase two
then we have the folic acid small
molecule drug conjugate approach so for
uh the folic acid conjugates can be used
to deliver the drug payload to the
cancer cells so uh
so what what it
um involves is that folic acid can be
conjugated using
cleavable bonds and these can carry the
drug payload to the cancer cell once
this
once
the folic acid binds to the receptor it
is internalized and the internal ph of
the endosome will result in the cleavage
of the folic acid from its receptor and
also release the drug payload now once
the drug payload is released the folate
receptor recycles back to the cell
membrane and the drug is
is
delivered at low concentration to the
cancer cells
so that is a very interesting approach
and our work is in that direction
however we have made some changes which
i will be talking about
so winter foliate is one such molecule
where they have tested a vinca alkaloid
and they have tried to uh deliver it to
cancer cells this molecule showed a lot
of promise
however it is now out of phase 3 trials
so keeping all this
in mind
we looked into the literature and
curcumin which is a well-known
spice which is used in indian food and
it has a lot of medicinal property
we looked into this molecule it's a
wonder molecule because it has
a whole range of
activity
and shows very lot of promise but there
are some
things which have to be taken care of so
it has been associated with antioxidant
anti-inflammatory anti-cancer antiviral
antibacterial
properties
it is also known to chemosensitize many
chemotherapeutic agents such as
5-fluorouracil doxorovicin paclitaxels
is platinum etc
the only uh drawback of this molecule is
its poor bioavailability and poor
absorption so
that is what limits its use
in the clinical setting
so
keeping in mind the multiple targets
that this molecule
is known to modulate
we have designed our own small molecule
drug conjugate
which comprises of folic acid
there is a spacer unit which connects it
to curcumin and finally there is a
cleavable bond
that is uh connecting to anti-cancer
drug and we have used paclitaxel we have
used
um acid-sensitive
cleavable bonds which can cleave at in
the acidic ph of uh
of the endosome
so i'm going to share some of the
results that preliminary results that
we've got with this triple conjugate
that we have designed uh we have uh
tested our conjugate in uh the uh
cervical cancers cancer cell lines like
hela and seahaw cell lines and what we
find when we do the mtt assay of these
compounds uh is that our conjugate is uh
working as good as um the known drug
doctor of the sin which is which is
really important because uh curcumin
might be assisting in its um
in um in the drug entering the cancer
cell
the cell proliferation assay also um
when we compare it with curcumin
toxiribusin and with untreated cells we
see that it is showing comparable
activity in at 12 and 24 hours both in
heli and seahaw cell lines
in order to look at
its
ability to enter the cells because it's
a large molecule
is it able to really enter the cells so
we have carried out these
studies where we have seen that our
molecule is able to uh enter the cells
and this green fluorescence that you are
seeing is of curcumin which has entered
the cancer cells uh after treatment at
we have seen it at six hours and 18
hours uh using not only curcumin but
also
the conjugate and our conjugate
exhibited better
fluorescence as compared to curcumin
which is evident from the figures
we also carried out some
in-vitro cell migration assay using our
conjugate uh doxorubicin and curcumin
and with the controls and what we found
is that in case of the con
the untreated cells
whereas there was 100 percent migration
of cells but when uh when we treated
with
either of the agents we could see that
cell migration was very much inhibited
um
by using the conjugate specifically
so we've also compared the apoptosis of
our
uh we have carried out the apoptosis
assay with our conjugate curcumin and
toxo ribosome in the same cell lines and
we find that
this molecule this conjugate in fact uh
shows uh the cells are
more apoptotic uh when we treat them
with the triple conjugate
so just to summarize uh
what we have
got so far
is that a conjugate
is uh exhibiting better cytotoxic
activity as compared to curcumin or
oxirapism alone uh there is a thirty to
seventy percent reduction in cell
proliferation in both pillar and csl
lines
in our optic experiment we did see that
uh the
conjugate could uh
internalize in the cell and we have seen
it visually that um
more concentration of the conjugate or
curcumin which is
could be seen inside the cell which
means that uh indeed the conjugate was
internalized inside the cell
the scratch assay
again
showed significant reduction in the
migration rate
as compared to the untreated controls
and the apoptosis assay after treatment
with curcumin doxorubicin um showed that
uh the apoptosis rate was uh much higher
when
when we uh used our
conjugate so all these studies gave us a
lot of confidence and now we are
proceeding ahead with uh more in bible
studies um
for our
conjugate and we believe that curcumin
would be uh the game changer for this uh
for this conjugate because it it is
assisting
in the entry of the drug by
chemosensitizing the cell of course most
studies are required for it but
our preliminary results
indicate that probably curcumin is
assisting and the drug is able to enter
the cell at low concentration so if it
is able to enter at low concentration uh
we are able to also target the cell so
we expect that the off-target toxicity
will be taken care of and at low
concentration we are expecting similar
results as compared to the
known drug
so um
my next part of my presentation is about
the graduate and the post graduate
programs at at my department so we are
we are amity institute of biotechnology
at amity university um and we offer a
lot of programs in the area of
biotechnology which includes b-tech
b-tech bioinformatics bsc programs in
biotechnology uh bsc-msc dual btec dual
three continent programs
and
we also offer bsc biotechnology and b8
courses
and
for our postgraduate programs also we
are offering
the mba biotechnology program msc by
biotechnology bioinformatics mtech
biotechnology and of course our phd
programs we also have some certificate
programs in artificial intelligence we
have masters of technology in
bioinformatics
so it's a big focus in our department
and we have
a large number of students who are
really interested
in all aspects of biotechnology
our institution also offers many
opportunities for international
opportunities for students which
include the student exchange programs
the which are offered in france where
students can spend a semester abroad
and complete their studies in a foreign
university we offer study abroad
programs at four or five locations all
over the world and this these are
available to all students ug and pg
students at amity institute of
biotechnology we also have
a very unique three continent program
now this program uh
we have
three streams in which we run them the
btec biotech three continent bsc medical
biotech three continent and the bse
honors biotech three continent so in
this the students
complete most of their studies in india
but in the last semester they travel to
uk and u.s for three months each and
finally they get their degree from amity
university
we are also collaborating with many
universities abroad and we are offering
international collaborative programs in
b-tech bioinformatics btec biotechnology
international again it is a two plus two
program uh with indiana university and
the bsc honors biotechnology program is
with the university of queensland
australia it's a one plus two program so
students have a plethora of
opportunities uh if they join the
department and uh truly uh we believe in
creating global citizens
at amity and our students have always
made us proud
so
and we hope to continue the same in
future
so thank you very much
thank you for
your patient hearing if there are any
questions i am ready to answer them
thank you very much for this
presentation we do have a few brief
questions here um one of them are
are there any specific techniques
required to synthesize these kinds of
molecules
humans conjugate
yes so conjugation chemistry would all
involve chemical synthesis of the
conjugates but yes it's very important
to
characterize whether conjugation really
took place or not so
of course you would be using ir nmr and
you have to use since it's a large
molecule so you may have to
go for malditov to
know the molecular weight of the
molecule so all that is very important
because
just carrying out the synthesis does not
mean that the conjugate got made you
have to characterize it
and a lot of people are asking about how
they would join your department or your
programs so if you could please
post a link to the department page to
learn about the program a little bit
more
yes i will just do that in the chat box
i will do that
thank you very much and so now you can
pass it on to you to introduce the next
speaker thank you very much dr bhatnagar
thank you thank you
thank you ma'am thank you
thank you so much professor seema
vatnagar now i would like to welcome dr
sona vasudevan dr sona vasudevan in
trust spans the areas of structural
biology structural bioinformatics
homology modeling protein ligand and
antibody antigen interactions in rna
biology her research interests include
comparative genomics protein
classification protein homology modeling
and molecular dynamics simulation to
look at the effect of single nucleotide
polymorphisms in breast cancer
evolutionary analysis systems biology
and translational informatics dr sona
vasudevan would be talking about the
systems medicine education at georgetown
uh
university over to you dr sona
thank you sonalika for that wonderful
introduction um
uh thank you uh elia for the um amazing
opportunity to be part of this
symposium i've enjoyed it very
thoroughly
so uh good morning good afternoon good
evening good night i know there are lots
of participants from different parts of
this world
um so i'm just going to spend the next
15-20 minutes to tell you about
um let me share my screen
okay i hope you can see my slides here
yes ma'am we can see your screen thank
you
yes so i'm going to spend the next 15-20
minutes to tell you about an educational
program
uh that we have developed at georgetown
university which is masters in systems
medicine
um of course before i dwell into the
details of the program i want to let you
all know those of you not visited
washington dc
uh you're welcome to visit because it's
actually a very beautiful place out here
especially especially during the spring
and georgetown university of course has
expert faculty
and a beautiful environment
as well
so before i dwell into
the program itself
i i'm not sure how many of you have
heard of the term systems medicine
because this is a very new term
but i think it's becoming uh more and
more uh secondhand to those surfers who
actually
um practice informatics
so for those of you who are not heard of
this i just want to give you a brief
definition of what systems medicine is
this is a very
traditional definition developed by the
european systems medicine association so
it's a novel approach to medicine it is
the first step on the path to
personalized medicine
it's based on computer models in which
wise amounts of clinical data and the
end are used to analyze
health of individuals um and patients
um it promises um to further our
understanding of disease mechanisms to
boost efficacy treatments
and of course cut costs of health care
um so
in a nutshell what systems medicine
means is it's one aspect of personalized
medicine
um and we know that even with cobit
we're all experiencing there's no two
individuals exhibit the same symptoms
we have a wide variety of symptoms
affecting wide variety of age groups
and a wide variety of outcomes
so
you know this is the practical
definition of systems medicine
it is a multi-discipline
field that looks at an individual as a
whole
it uses systems biology and
computational sciences genomics
technologies to help solve bio
biomedical problems
and it is the future of medicine and i'm
sure you all will agree with me with the
explosion of data out there uh there is
no uh going away from looking at data
and putting things together uh we had
lots of interesting talks yesterday in
the symposium about different
integration techniques of all of this
omig data and and what the dire need for
educating
um informations and dr patnagar at amity
just
talked about amazing programs
to expand this field of informatics and
that is extremely welcome
so in summary what systems medicine is
all about
is
the realization
that one size does not fit all
two patients with the same symptoms same
findings
same disease
are given the same drug
but each patient exhibits different
outcomes
different reactions to these drugs
and why does this happen why does drug
response vary way
this is what gives us the dimension
multi-dimensional problem to solve which
is at hand right now
so it all boils down to individual
variations between
two different
individuals individual patients
and these individual variations
stem from genetic differences between
individuals it could be as simple as one
single nucleated polymorphism
i don't have to emphasize to this
audience that majority of the diseases
that we see is actually caused by single
nucleotide changes sickle cell anemia is
just one single mutation
and we're talking about a lot of
variants right now so it's all um single
nucleated variations so there are lots
of variations that exist among human
population
and there is ethnicity differences age
genetic factors diseases drug drug
interactions
environment
nutrition so these are all some of the
major factors
that lead to different drug responses
among the different individuals
and why are we talking about this right
now um i don't have to again emphasize
to this audience audience
so at the mids we are at the midst of an
era of big biology biological data and
we so happen to be in the middle of a
pandemic as well
and a revolution in medical practice is
happening as we speak with all of this
data coming from different atomic
technologies
so it all started here with the human
genome project
more than two decades ago
it would
successfully we were able to map the
total number of human genes
sequenced human genes of course we are
still continuing to sequence the human
genome to get the most accurate picture
of it
but today we stand here knowing that
we have
the number of total number of genes in
the human system is about 20 thousand to
twenty one thousand
um so this is actually this initiated a
whole cascade of different
avenues to pursue and of course when the
good news about the human genome
sequencing project was completed all of
us including myself celebrated thinking
that this is the beginning of end of a
cure for all diseases but here we stand
after two decades we are still
not there yet we have made lots of
progress but we're still not there yet
because of the complexity that exists in
the human human genome itself
of course omics space all of you are
familiar with lots and lots of different
omics um that is and we are in the
middle of a genomic era so ohmic space
is actually the pillar of systems
medicine uh so we have lots of uh
different
layers of ohmic genomics transcriptomics
proteomics you name it
and genomics is being used to integrate
pathways made into genes struggling
interactions for various diseases
to add to all of this complexity
we are now dealing with another omics
which is the microbiome
uh with all of these individual
organisms that we all carry alongside
with our alongside our human genome and
human cells as well so these are all the
different omics where we have
a huge amount of data coming out of all
of this
and now the challenge that faces us is
how do we
look at and integrate all of this and
come up with an understanding of
diseases and understanding of human
biology
so genomics has become an universal
diagnostic tool in in clinics right now
and to understand the molecular
mechanisms of diseases i can't even
think any other way of looking at a
disease right now
even when i did my phd about two decades
ago
all we did was study one gene one
protein and the implication of
one gene and the mutations in it in a
disease
but here we can't do that anymore
because we have come to an understanding
that diseases are defined multiplex of
course i'm not talking with the
monogenic diseases majority of the
disease is more complex than that so
this has led us to
look at genomics and now we are
currently using that as a diagnostic too
too
um so systems medicine is already in
clinics and it's surfacing in various
different ways
big data using large datasets to learn
about gender population clinical
decisions and all of those things
of course reproductive endocrinology
testing embryos so potentially fatal
conditions where we are here doing all
of this today
um genetic testing is available widely
um and we're able to
catch a lot of
metabolic disorders in newborns
and tumor profiling music genetics to
taylor cancer treatments by tracking
mutations and pharmacogenomics assessing
individuals perspective related reaction
to a drug based on their genetic
specific makeup so we are already seeing
systems medicine in a day-to-day
practice of what we are doing
and here i stand today to let you know
that the other cell revolution in
medical practice
and and we are all about
uh efforts about disease prevention and
promoting health
that is our goal
so all of this data and all of this has
made us realize
that we are learning a new language
and it has led us to realize that we
actually need new educational programs
to learn this new new language
and this uh this education in my opinion
has to start from um schools high
schools or undergrads
um and so georgetown university we
realized this uh about a decade ago
and also of course all of you will agree
an investment in knowledge base the best
interest right so
so
that led us to create
a dual master's degree program in
systems medicine at georgetown
university
this was launched in 2011
uh and the program of course i'm not
going to go in depth about the
curriculum itself um there may not be
much time but i'm happy to talk about it
and send you some links that um and you
could go and look at the details of the
curriculum
the curriculum for this master's program
mainly was intended for students in
medical school who are completed years
of medical curriculum because these are
physicians that are going to be using
this data through treating you and me
so this program was intended to intended
to generate a new type of physician
one with the grasp of modern
computational sciences and opic
technologies genomics proteomics
methodology and translational sciences
etc so that they can embrace this into
their practice of medicine
when they are looking at that and of
course more importantly to understand
the system's approach to medicine uh
because one size as i mentioned one size
does not fit all and it is not about one
chain one protein uh it is about a whole
systems that actually we have to look at
in order to understand a disease
so uh after a successful launch of a
dual degree program we came to the
realization that this language has to be
taught to all students no matter what
the career paths might be
so that led us to create another
master's program
which is a free freestanding master's
program um in 2016 and it was intended
for any student
who's interested in
understanding biomedical
any discipline in my biomedical sciences
this is a generate this is again to
generate a new type of scientist new
type of physician new type of
any health care individual who can also
learn this language to embrace that we
can so again more importantly to
understand persistence approach to
medicine and research
so we launched those two programs and
i'm not going to go deep into the
curriculum itself but just to
give you a flavor um students have to
complete 30 degree 30 credits of course
requirements
that includes core courses that each
student is actually trained in that
include biostatistics
biomedical informatics um journal
critically reading scientific literature
which is becoming actually very very
important unless you understand how to
read a scientific paper we're not going
to be able to understand what is out
there and to critically review different
techniques and technologies to make
amends and improvements to all of those
and to be able to understand
how to analyze clinical patient data
that's out there we have huge amount of
data that's available
in different resources
and of course as i mentioned microbiome
is becoming extremely important and how
what are the different organisms that
are up and down regulated in different
situations what is a normal biprobiota
so we have courses that teach the
students how to look at microbiome
and
what are the different aspects to
genomics and how do you take
data from bench to bedside and how do
you translate all of the data
and the experimental data that is out
there and
looking at metabolomics
with everything is about metabolomics
any reaction in our body is going to
give you metabolites so so this is the
um
a picture of the courses that students
actually learn
and of course in addition to the courses
students actually end up taking elective
courses based on their interests and
based on their career paths so we have
several different courses that span from
looking at drug design three-dimensional
structures
to looking at how do you think in
systems right and also how we create
policies and how do you look at all of
this uh in a lab and how do you learn
all of this so this is
of course the details of all of these
courses you can find it on our website
and students are allowed to take courses
across
the entire uh different departments at
georgetown they can learn about
epidemiology or they can learn about
diets they can learn about supplements
and all of those things
the most important part of the
curriculum is a capstone project so
students are mandated to do
a good portion of their time they spend
doing research
so you can learn as much as you want in
a class setting listening to lectures
but unless you know how to
uh learn how you learn to apply these in
a research setting uh it's not going to
be a practical use
and we will be educating these students
to use of those all of these different
uh techniques and resources and tools
that they learn in the class setting so
capstone is a very integral part of the
program
and students spend more than 240 hours
doing research and the research
culminates in a poster presentation and
majority of the students end up
publishing being part of a publication
um so which as
they learn how to write a paper they
publish a paper and
they know how to apply
all of the tools that they learn so
research is an integral part of the
program
and students have variety of options to
go and do their mentor internships we
have several mentors this is just only a
flavor of the institutions in and around
georgetown where students actually
go and do
their mentoring of course in addition to
all of this students
have mentors in industry and other
university uh universities as well so we
have a wide network of collaborations
across different universities and
industry
settings
um so the question is
what are the skill sets that these
students
actually get out of this program and if
you are out there looking to hire these
are all the skill sets that they get so
they understand what is big data so what
it means to actually deal with humongous
amount of data so they also understand
what sequencing means they understand
how to
um carry out next in sequence analysis
rmseq analysis microbiome data analysis
so they are exposed to how to do
use the data and meaningfully extract
knowledge from these data
we also teach by chemistry which i think
is fundamental whether you're a
researcher or whether you are a
physician or anything you i have to
understand biochemistry but the way we
teach biochemistry is based on cases
it is about patients cases so they
understand that a patient walks into the
clinic
has these symptoms and they understand
how to troubleshoot to figure out which
gene is going how we can then what
mutations they have which pathways is
implicated so that they have an
understanding of the disease from a
systems perspective
and thanks to bind biotech and ilia we
have been able to launch a course on
machine learning
and ai and i'm very excited about this
so students learn
machine learning as well aspects and
they also learn about
healthcare in terms of electronic health
records electronic medical records how
do you mine them how do you get value
uh how do you take uh basic research to
from bench to bedside um and they also
of course learn learn how to read an
article scientific scientific article
which is actually very very important
for you to be able to distinguish
between
good papers and
critically thinking um and analyzing the
results of a publication they also learn
how to mine patient data how they use
inflation data how do you understand uh
the forms of all of these patient last
but not the least they also
um learn to get their hands a little bit
wet to understand how do you generate
good dna or rna that can be sent for
sequencing and what are the caveats in
them so how do you understand between
good data good sequencing data and bad
sequencing data so we use we expose them
to the nanocore sequencer so
they learn how to actually hold the
sequencer and do the sequencing so these
are all
um the skill sets that the students
actually learn
from the program
and there is something for everyone
so those students who actually come to
us for the mpms
program they of course go and become
physicians um and those students who
actually do the ms program going to go
on to go to medical school nursing
school pa or go schools or um go into
phd programs or work in industries
academic settings and of course health
cares and doctors offices so there is
something
for everyone in the program so we are
all about skill sets and so they develop
lots of skill sets that they can apply
in different industries and different
job settings
um so the question that's always asked
us where are the graduates now so the
graduates are all over the place here
some of them are are in medical schools
phd programs nursing schools um and of
course several of them are working in
several different universities um
fda and all of those so um so the
students get placed pretty well
and uh of course why georgetown and i'm
proud to say that the program is the
first in the nation and of course we
have outstanding faculty and we have an
outstanding team um to help us
uh of course it all boils down to
whether we have scholarships that we
support the students yes we do have
several different scholarships that
students can apply to um so we have an
endowment of hundred thousand dollars
that was generously provided by robert
stephen lightly um um
endowment scholarships and we also have
lots of different biomedical graduate
scholarships of course all of the
details are um okay you can find it in
the website and i'll post the link to
our website uh in a second
of course it's not all about academics
students have a very good life
we go out for lunches we party we
celebrate different things
uh and we have a social life as well and
there's a wonderful academic life as
well students attend conferences they
present their work
they they are taking field trips to the
nih uh do they see the sequencing
facilities and you can see all of them
are smiling so the program does treat
them well
um and so they do have in addition to
their
academic life they do have a good social
life as well um so this is the website
to the program if you want to learn more
um and i just want to actually leave a
few minutes for questions
uh so that i can elaborate on anything
else that you may need
from this and i want to thank you for
your attention and if i'm happy to take
any questions you may have
okay thank you very much dr vasudevan we
do have a question do you have an
opinion on the advancement of alpha fold
that will change the scene and structure
biology field in the near future
that's actually an outstanding question
i am a structural biologist but i am a
structural biologist by training myself
and yes it is going to
uh completely revolutionize the way we
are going to do structural biology and
as you know that um already you know
people are using
ai and machine learning and in fact we
have a structural biology team at
georgetown university who have actually
used the concepts to come up with uh
some
you know therapeutics for cobit uh 19.
uh and the answer is yes i've been
waiting for this and the answer is yes
this is going to
move uh the field com very fast
so that we'll be able to design drugs in
a much more systematic manner as well
what we could not do before we're able
to do because we don't have to depend on
experimental sciences ah but of course
there are lots of caveats too we are not
there yet but we are getting there and i
think this is definitely going to
revolutionize um i'm very excited i'm
actually
learning and using it myself
so the answer is yes
okay thank you very much so in your
opinion how do you see someone with the
master's degree in molecular biology and
genetics fit into systems medicine
oh um actually
i would definitely welcome in fact i
would love to have students who have the
background in biology and genetics to be
able to contribute to informatics as you
know informatics is actually an
application field we do depend on
experimental biologists and the
knowledge from experimental biologists
to make sense of all of this data that
is coming out and in fact uh most of my
students who come actually i i require
that they have a biology background and
if you have a molecular biology
background and genetics uh that's an
added i it will be an asset to have such
expertise in the program
and you will actually gain much more uh
than just um
a person uh without a little bit of
biology background
and so the final question is two part
questions so do you have any
international students that join your
program
and if somebody like that wants to apply
uh how are they going to
handle the registration and fees it
seems like the program is very expensive
well this is actually some of my heart
bleeds because i do want a lot of
international students and what limits
is the expense yes i the answer the
first part of the question the answer is
yes i do have
international students
i have graduated almost about seven or
eight international students
um in the program since its inception in
2016
and i know that expense is a big a big
problem and i'm trying to find funds uh
there are merit paid scholarships that
the program uh provides um and if you
have a merit-based uh if you are you
qualify for that you definitely of
course it's not a lot of money so that
is something that i'm actively pursuing
to figure out how to generate revenue so
that i can
um create more scholarships for
international students um so we do have
a lot of international students actually
judged on and and personally i do in
fact i have a couple of international
students who are going to be starting
tomorrow
uh for this fall
um
okay so thank you very much we do have a
lot of other questions here but we're
not going to have time to answer all of
them uh there is a link
that maybe you could share on the chat
as well for anybody who wants to learn
more and you can also go to our
symposium page we have links to all of
the participants
or sorry all the speakers uh all of the
links you can find there okay so monica
over to you thank you very much dr
vasudevan great to hear about all this
yeah thank you so much thank you all for
your patience
thank you so much dr sona vasudevan
now i would like to welcome dr philip
camp q he would be talking on
undergraduate in high school
computational biology education at
carnegie mellon university
dr phillip is an associate teaching
professor and assistant department head
in the computational biology department
at carnegie mellon university he is a
passionate educator who has taught a
range of stem courses to a diverse
collection of student groups an
experienced administrator who works to
make the student the central focus of
our educational programs and a leader of
several successful projects in open
online education over to you dr phillip
okay thank you so much for the kind
introduction i'm going to share my
screen
and you can find information about our
department at
cbd.cmu.edu so we have a nice short url
and that's going to have information
about the the programs that i'm talking
about today as well as
all of our educational program so we're
in in pittsburgh pennsylvania in in the
us
um we have a phd program that's joint
with the university of pittsburgh which
is actually just down the street from
our university it's kind of rare to have
two universities that actually
are
directly adjacent to each other
we also have two master's programs one
in computational biology and another in
automated science so we have opened
a laboratory that is totally robotically
driven where students can learn about
how to not just program the robot to
perform experiments in biology but also
to train the robot to make decisions
about what future experiments to run
based off of the results of experiments
so you have this closed-loop
experimentation system
but what i was going to talk about today
is is two projects that i have
essentially
created
one and serve as a director of
one is our undergraduate degree in
computational biology and another is a
high school program that i founded with
josh kangas
that educates students over the summer
within the field of computational
biology and that program makes us
somewhat unique so i i i'm very proud of
both of these programs i know that
others you know may talk about more
graduate education but i wanted to share
the type of thing that we do with with
both undergraduate and high school
students um if you're interested in our
other programs i would encourage you to
go to our website and check them out
because we have wonderful programs for
every variety of
of interest
so
in our undergraduate program
we accept students directly to colleges
within carnegie mellon so at most
american universities you just apply to
the university
and then when you arrive you decide on
what your major is going to be and
everybody can decide on whatever major
and then that means that in many places
computer science has like
you know thousands of people um at a
time and and so it makes it very
difficult to have any sort of personal
relationships or this type of thing
because you have just huge classrooms
and you're just getting students through
we're a little bit different in that
students apply to schools based off of
their interests and so our department is
one of seven departments within the
school of computer science the others
are things like human computer
interaction machine learning and so on
and we have a very very selective school
so
it's one of the most selective
institutions in the u.s
the acceptance rate is only
unfortunately about five percent that
means that we don't get to see as many
talented students as we probably could
we're one of four majors that students
can choose from once they're accepted
the others being computer science
artificial
intelligence and human computer
interaction
and all the four of those major students
are trained very very computationally
first so there may there are plenty of
bioinformatics
um majors out there already most of them
are aimed towards biologists and i think
what differentiates us is that we are
training computational scientists first
and foremost you know we keep hearing
about the computational and big data
revolution in biology
and so um certainly our students receive
a great deal of biological training we
have an entire core of study that's
devoted to
biological foundational coursework but
we feel that that it's just as important
to train them as computational
scientists alongside some of the
smartest undergraduate minds in computer
science in the world
and then we have an entire core of
computational biology coursework that
sits at the intersection of all this
math and computer science and biology
and physics and cabinet students take
and what's nice about this is that those
core cs math requirements are the same
that computer science majors get so we
know that our students are being put
through a very very rigorous
kind of world famous training process at
the undergraduate level
one of the cool things that this means
that we can do
is our students come in and they take
a mathematics course that's usually even
by math majors only taken as juniors or
seniors where they they prove theorems
and learn about discrete mathematics our
students do that in their first semester
we know they come in as very very
talented programmers or if they're not
they become very talented programmers
quickly
um and so in our second semester we
teach students an entire course devoted
to what we call great ideas in compile
so that's our first
cohort that we had
and it's if you search for that i should
be easy to find i've got an entire
website about the course it contains
slides and descriptions of some of our
student projects that they did as well
as kind of the philosophy of the course
and how we've set it up
um we have a collection of course aims
the the i like talking about this course
just a little bit because i've uh
founded it with carl kingsford and i've
taught it for three years
where the central aim is to show
students what has made biology a
computational discipline it's
inherently a data-driven computational
discipline in 2021
and so we tell the story so to speak of
what has happened to make that the case
so um throughout this we find that you
know there you know there's these sub
aims of for example you have fundamental
algorithmic topics like dynamic
programming that comes up several times
throughout the course
we take this big broad view of
computational biology to find really
cool ideas outside of standard topics
i'll mention that briefly here in a
second
we profile topics that have actually
been so important that they've gone off
and and informed things that are outside
of biology and computer science
things like how blast works really you
know for for database search or things
like neural networks
we also point students towards primary
research that any moment of the course
i'm always show students the actual
research papers that this came from
whether it comes from 1970 or whether it
comes from just a few years ago soon our
students do group projects and we also
plug in world leading researchers to to
give guest lectures to our students as
well so they can see that this is very
much a living and breathing discipline
when when we teach these first-year
students the first half of the course is
devoted to these classic topics in
genomics things like the brown graphs
for genome assembly things like
global and local sequence alignment
smith waterman algorithm read mappings
we explain how the burrows wheeler
transform works and and how that's
applied to read mapping you know again
this is the sort of thing that you would
typically see in maybe a phd level class
or maybe a final semester undergrad
course but we're able to teach it to
first-year uh undergraduates
and then in the second half of the
course we take this big uh broader view
of what computational biology is and we
cover things that within systems biology
we talk about the foundations of neural
networks as well as you know explore how
this has affected uh this really neat
algorithm called the elon kashtan
algorithm and systems biology
we also talk about algorithms in nature
we talk about spatial and evolutionary
game theory turing patterns things that
you might not typically see in a one
year or one semester
overview course
pretty much because they're beautiful
ideas that have led to a lot of other
cool work um even if they aren't you
know at the at the forefront of what is
going on in computational biology today
one of the other cool things about our
undergrad degree is that we guarantee at
least one semester of research to all of
our majors that goes back to our point
about going to university and finding
yourself one of a thousand other majors
in a certain subject and it being a
battle to be able to have any sort of
research experience we only have
about 20 majors per year and so that
means that we can pair our faculty with
all students who want to do research and
we do this because
it's what our students told us they
wanted so when we met with prospective
students the kids kept saying over and
over again you know i really want to
come here so i can do research what can
you do and so we work with our faculty
to guarantee that
um
we also connect our students downstream
to opportunities outside of
um you know their degree we know that
our degree is very expensive to the
point that was just race and we want to
do everything that we can to help
students of all
in all of our programs get connected to
opportunities in industry um often
hearing from what our alums are doing so
this is at one of our events and we hold
these virtually as well we send resume
books of students um to to alums and
contacts in industry and so on and we
also try to have fun with our students
too so um even when it's cold in
pittsburgh in the winter time we find
something to do with them uh going snow
tubing
so um that's a kind of
a big picture about what we do with our
undergrad degree
and our undergraduate degree has only
recently graduated its first
students who have had transferred in
from other majors
our first main cohort
because we we started four years ago our
first main cohort is going to be
graduating this spring so
it'll be exciting to see all the sorts
of things that they head off to do
although we know they're they're
interested in
medical careers whether or not that
means within medical school or not
or going off to industry whether that's
biotech pharma or a traditional tech
firm
so that's one of the programs that i
wanted to discuss and the other is our
high school program in computational
biology that's one of
a suite of programs that
is offered by carnegie mellon so i think
there are 11 high school programs that
we have over the summer
that are all taught by professors
and that allows students to come to
campus under normal circumstances and
have kind of a student experience on
campus for our program runs for three
weeks
some of the programs run for six weeks
where students are in the classroom
full-time throughout the day or doing
working on something um you know for
eight hours a day for every weekday um
and so we have this very intensive
you know full-time program for a short
period of time with with rising seniors
in high school so 16 17 year old
students um
we told students you know when we
started
just as we communicate our our goals for
my first year undergrad course we
communicate our goals very very upfront
for our high school program too
so we tell students the first and
foremost thing that we want to do is
have fun what's wonderful about this and
i'll tie this to point number five
is that we um we don't assign grades
there's no
metric
of success in our program other than
just learning there's not no
deliverables students complete a short
project but in terms of the core content
that they're learning the goal of the
program is solely to learn and to have
fun doing so
um
so that means we can really challenge
students too because there are no stakes
we don't have students climbing climbing
over each other to try and get a higher
grade so they can move on and get into
the next school it's not something that
we have to to worry about frankly um
as part of this students usually will
learn a new programming language so we
currently use go we may change that in
the future but we use a language that's
kind of outside of what students
typically do so that students don't come
in and say well i already know how to
program in python because this way
students will learn something new
regardless
we want them to appreciate that
computation is everywhere in biology
that biology is a very much a
computational discipline in 2021 and we
want students to write their own code so
kind of the full cycle of how our
program works is that we present
students with some biological program
problem
we explain to them how we're going to
solve it computationally we then show
how you might do this by breaking it up
into smaller pieces but the students
solve all of those pieces and then put
them back together into a very large
piece of code that they can then apply
to some real biological data set those
real biological data sets are taken from
either
the microbiome of the three rivers in
pittsburgh so we have two rivers that
flow together into a third and the two
rivers are very different from each
other they flow through different sorts
of environments one goes by a lot of
steel mills the other is much more rural
and so we captured on a boat we went out
and got
water samples with our students from
different seasons and we got a lot of
data sets um metagenomics data sets
but we also use the opportunity of the
pandemic to
uh look at publicly available genome
data sets for
for sars cove too as well so but our
main topic of focus is in microbiology
um and we communicate to students how
our classroom works so just as we
communicate up front our goals we tell
students why we've set up the program in
the way that we have so we talk to them
about active learning and about how if
we can get our students to do as much in
the classroom as possible as opposed to
just listening to me drone on
and receiving information that
regardless of their background
they will see a market increase
in
what their uh outcome is so in their
ability um and that often this doesn't
feel like the experience of learning and
other studies have shown that even
though students are objectively learning
more via active learning
they feel like they're learning less and
we tell students that that that feeling
of
uh
internal struggle is what learning feels
like
we
use this sort of research educational
research to inform a transition to our
online classroom so
over the past two years we've had to run
this program remotely to students across
the country
and
we use best practices for this one of
the things that we do partly based off
of student input
is uh we now have students solve
problems in teams of four or five so at
most points of the program students are
working together to solve some coding
challenge
and they're in small groups doing this
and they can code all in one window
that's shared through something called
atom
so they can all see the same coding
window and then they can all run the
code together
so this creates this really nice kind of
group
dynamic where students have input from
teaching assistants and input from us
the instructors as we're roaming around
but they're all working together
constantly
so that even though they're online
they're able to really uh do something
all the time in the program so what is
it that we cover um
remember i mentioned our three rivers we
ask you know how is it that the bacteria
that are present in these rivers change
over time how are they different from
one river to the other um how is
seasonality important to this and we use
this to to come up with simple metrics
that are the metrics that are used by
biologists but very easy to explain
metrics for quantifying the diversity of
a single bacterial sample or comparing
two bacterial samples and sprinkle a
little machine learning magic on this to
produce
a plot like this one that shows that
seasonality is more important than
location for determining bacterial
diversity in the three rivers
in the second module of the course and
so i've put all the lines of code that
students write or that we have as our
official solutions
um and it shows i think it's to show how
much code that students will write
because
typically
when students are solving some coding
challenge we don't
continue until all the groups are
finished we were worried about whether
or not that would be possible given that
many of our students have never
programmed until like two months before
our program when we send them some
preparatory materials but then all of
our groups pretty much solve every
single one of our problems so when we
say total number of lines of code this
is
you know students are writing this much
code and using it to solve biological um
examples the next this module is about
you know comparing genes whether it's a
database search
and we talk about blast we don't code
the entire blast algorithm but we
discuss how it works but what we do
code are things like smith waterman
sequence alignment and the students all
code it themselves and then they apply
it to something like comparing stars
cove to source code 2 um so they can
actually see
something that we hear about in the news
which for example which is that the
variation of sars cove is you know
isolated to you know different points
you have a variable variation throughout
the genome so they can see that based
off of the code that they produced we
even write a genome assembler with our
students
which is our largest coding project it's
they're coding as fast as they can go
and we apply it to both simulated and
real data to show that on our simulated
data that has you know some error rate
um our assembler this is a mummer pod on
the left our assembler does really good
job at assembling the source code 2
genome it does an okay job on real data
when we cut it loose on real data and we
use this as an opportunity to show that
there's pretty much always improvements
that we can make even after we write
1400 lines of code if we really wanted a
real genome assembler that would truly
work on a viral data set it might need
to be 10 times as long as that and if we
were going to apply it to bacteria it
might need to be a hundred times as long
but once we can assemble the genome we
can find the genes in it so we have a
short module for students to find genes
and we use this to build a simple
annotation of something like a viral
genome as well as to compare
our gene finder against annotation for a
longer
larger organism and students even with a
simple approach are able to reconstruct
like 80 percent of the genes um in say a
sequence uh annotated bacterium
and then in the final module of our
class we produce evolutionary trees and
we apply this to a variety of different
contexts so we look at for example
coronavirus
genomes taken from patients in different
countries to understand the initial
spread of the chronovirus around the
world we also
have students implement a simple version
of cluster
so that this is the actual um alignment
that that came from students code
so that they can start looking through
this you know throughout the course of
the pandemic
and identifying not just identifying the
variance but defining the variance
themselves and then we compare the
student definition against say the cdc's
definition what is it that makes an
alpha variant what is it that makes the
delta variant and then we can allow
students to classify each of our genomes
in some database say the uk patient
genome database to classify each patient
genome
according to which variant it applies to
and this is we just do you know normal
alpha and delta but even with this
simple classifier that we build we can
see the percentages of the alpha variant
go up you know very highly in in early
2021 and then it's completely replaced
with the delta variant so students again
have this feeling that they're really
doing the research themselves there's
nothing that the real biological
researchers did that they couldn't have
done themselves now that they have this
knowledge um finally i i point out you
know we have very very strong teaching
evaluations for our
for our program but there have been some
qualitative feedback that i love to
profile here because it reinforces our
original goals
most students when they learn to program
they learn about it in the context of
math when they think about computer
science they're thinking about google or
facebook or amazon and it's unfortunate
that even though this computational
revolution has happened our students
even very very strong students many of
whom come from very privileged
high school backgrounds have no idea
that programming can be used to solve
very important problems in biology
and that you know many of these problems
are very new for example with respect to
the pandemic
they love the collaboration that we have
um
they really appreciate the challenge
one student has called called it
grueling this year but then said
something very positive so if we're able
to balance extreme challenge
without frustrating or stressing out our
students then we really know that we're
doing our job and then i always give my
favorite quote is from nia
um who was interviewed by a blog
to discuss her her experience not just
in our program but with the pre-college
program at cmu as a whole
um and it was wonderful to see that
something that we don't tell our
students is that we pair them up based
off of their backgrounds based off of
their geography uh making sure that all
of our our groups are are um
kind of ethnically and gender diverse
and
uh she
we didn't tell our students this but she
recognized hey i know that they created
our groups to be as diverse as possible
often with different backgrounds strong
biologists or strong computational
students
and that that's what made the teams work
so well um so she was a wonderful
student i should say but um i always try
to end with with her quote i'm happy to
answer any questions i don't know where
we are on time but thank you for
listening
thank you very much for this
presentation we are just very short on
time in fact one minute over time but it
was great to hear
about this program we do have just uh
maybe a couple of questions that we can
fit in
uh the first one is do you accept high
school students from different states uh
for example the state of louisiana and
if yes do you have a summer program that
is online or face to face and if you
have a link for that
yeah so we we accept students from
around the world when we're in person
and we're hoping to be in person
next summer so you can find if you go to
our
um
go to our department website or
there's a pre-college carnegie mellon if
you just google pre-college carnegie
mellon you'll find all of the programs
so it may be that you're interested you
find yourself interested in something
else and those are easy to find
all right thank you very much and it was
great to hear the presentation we're
hoping to learn more from the links that
you provided thank you
thank you so much dr philip for such an
uh such a great talk
and i've got i have received comments in
my personal chat box that people really
like the talk and it was very inspiring
for some of them as well
now we i would like to welcome dr gus
kasoulis he is a professor of virology
and biotechnology in the department of
pathobiological sciences and director of
the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine he is the director of
the nih funded center in experimental
infectious disease research and the
director of nih-funded louisiana
biomedical research network molecular
and cell biology code dr gus would be
talking on data science for biological
data a message for the national
association of idea principal
investigators over to you dr kass
hopefully you can see my screen
yes dr gus we can see your screen okay
well um i guess good morning or good
afternoon depending where you are
um thank you for the introduction i'm
very pleased to participate in this
important symposium it was exciting to
see the opportunities but the elite
universities at georgetown
and also at cmu
very exciting programs
i am the president of the national
association of idea principal
investigators and
this
is a 503c not-for-profit corporation
there is a think tank
that helps nih and specifically the
national institute of general medical
sciences
to sort of uh socialize uh and support
biomedical research within 23 states in
puerto rico and those 23 states in
puerto rico representing practically
half of the country
are those states that do not receive
high levels of nih funding and nih is
concerned about that and has created
this program
to support biomedical research
and specifically data science and
bioinformatics at the undergraduate and
graduate level with a focus on primary
primarily undergraduate institutions
so navy aims to
as i said be a think tank and advice and
aids on programs and how to really
support biomedical research
and it fosters interactions promotes
resources sharing enhances the
visibility of multiple programs i will
tell you a little bit about
and develops consensus priorities
disseminates best practices and
identifies opportunities and develop
strategies for excelling in biomedical
research
this is the leadership of the
nepea
i serve as the president and we have an
executive committee with dr doug wright
uh from kansas
uh dr yan mang uh from the university of
new england dr scott seville from
wyoming and dr julia oxford the
secretary from boise state um
we we the nether website i think is part
of my um
what i have disclosed here and you could
look at an episode uh for
all this information about what nate is
doing so again the mission of nep is to
provide leadership and communication for
development and promotion improvement of
biomedical research and uh as already
told you a lot of the goals is really
foster interaction support aura
constituents and stakeholders throughout
those programs
so a little bit briefly about the
history of the idea program the national
institutes of health developed
institutional development award or idea
program it was established in 93 to
broaden the geographic distribution of
united's funding for biomedical
behavioral research
the program fosters health-related
research and enhances the
competitiveness uh by investing in
institutions
located in states which the aggregate
success rate for applications on aids
has historically been law so it is to a
large extent manpower development
socializing uh supported by medical
research and supporting
in
much greater numbers
people that could pursue biomedical
research the program also serves unique
populations such as rural and medically
undeserved communities in this in these
states
so this is just a
brief idea about the funding
the current funding is approximately 400
million that's distributed among
different programs it started much lower
in
93 with approximately 30 million and has
been uh
rising uh hopefully hopefully attending
up to one percent of the budget and as
you can see one percent of the nih
budget that is actually distributed for
this uh programs competitive programs in
23 states and puerto rico
and
this programs have been fundamental
because they increase competitiveness
within the states
and leverages them to be able to compete
with categorical traditional funding by
nih
and
a number of our states because of this
funding have been able to compete and
get significant uh funding by competing
with much more developed institutions
and states
so
the five idea funding programs
is the centers of biomedical research
excellence discoveries
this program is really targeting to
graduate individual investigators with
r1 funding from nih it has been
fantastically successful
having
investigators reaching the first r1 at
younger age
in comparison to the average across the
states
uh and also promoting excellence of
biomedical research within specific
institutions
the imbre awards for which one i'm the
principal investigator is a different
type of award one for state they had 24
active awards and those have
a targeted focus on
promoting
the uh the promoting biomedical research
through primarily through
supporting
the primarily undergraduate institutions
and they have mandatory focus on
training and teaching and providing
support for data science and
bioinformatics and this is what i call
socializing uh learning for data science
because we'll reach
more than 50 000 undergraduates and what
are we trying to do through mapping
through these programs is really
provide free or very
low cost
training in bioinformatics and data
science
you also have the idea networks for
clinical translational research the idea
cprs the 20 active states the popular
translational research
uh we also support the nih supports uh
co-funding for our ones in our fifteenth
and has ten applications that come
within region of being funded by
categorical institute and we do have
four hubs that promote entrepreneurship
within the um idea network
so um the idea networks itself
and i will talk about some of the
specific things that nih is doing to
promote
data science and computational biology
through cloud computing training and
through google and amazon contracts
and the ctrs are clinical translational
centers that involve multiple medical
schools within the idea states
and there is a co-funding coordinator
that has been used to really help
people within states to achieve funding
through a categorical institute
and of course the idea regional
technology
centers have seen programs and they
teach business fundamentals for
technology for directors for
the inbree and kobe programs
the number other collaborations and
participations in nih-wide initiatives
i'll go briefly through this and you'll
have the slides to see this these are
really from
a recent town meeting that we had with
nih dr mingli presented
some of this
information so there is collaborations
among the idea programs there are
supplements that have been given to
cobra ctrs
for a number of different purposes
including a number of them for copy 19
research there are collaborations with
non-idea nice programs including the
maternal infant mortality research
uh the kobe 19 patient registry cloud
computing for biomedical research and
the nih strides program
that involves access to google and
amazon cloud computing and i'll say
something about that a little later we
also have a competing uh
participation in competition for nih
white research initiatives including the
active files for poker 19 therapeutics
and the rapid acceleration diagnostics
and front desired populations
so
a new program for nih that i think will
be important for some of you to know is
the shure program which is supported for
research excellence uh sure program and
this is really to target primarily
undergraduate institutions that serve
minorities and it has different programs
one is to support investigators
for nih research funding
and to support research excellence as a
first independent research award
and to build administrative
infrastructure broadening participation
and the uh the specific qualifications
for this up to uh 25 percent of the buck
of the students being served by pell
grants uh it replaces a number of the
opportunities that were provided
initially for minority institutions a
number of really small primarily
undergraduate institutions can compete
for these awards of course the injury
programs within state will assist
in any of those primarily undergraduate
institutions within these 23 states and
puerto rico to submit this competitive
awards to an aids
this again the map of the idea program
states
that he has
i told you involves the cobras inbreeze
idea ctrs
uh 23 states and puerto rico labeled
here this map as green
really there are the states that
have
a great population a lot of interest
unfortunately not the resources some of
the bigger states have in the elite
programs throughout the country and
nappy is facilitating accessing this
information and
representing all these idea states to
nih into the federal government
so nappy has done a number of
initiatives and we are in the process of
developing more
let's get this out of
here uh we will providing funding for
idea undergraduate students to travel to
washington dc every other year we have a
national meeting where over a thousand
people attending in washington dc
um and we'll provide travel funds for
that
we're awarding awards for undergraduate
graduates and assistant professors for
best presentations in our regional
meetings which are also every other year
uh overlapping um every other year
regional meetings and then the national
meeting the access to idea-wide
databases and we provide
free access to virtual training courses
and exercises created by df faculty and
discounts to other virtual forces in
data science and mathematics we have
really had a collaboration with find
biotech and we're providing a number of
these courses free of charge or with low
charges throughout our network
accessing more than 50 000 students
we also have gonna have job postings and
job searches in the idea program
uh we also were proud that we are uh
co-sponsors uh for the uh this
particular symposium which provides
i think tremendous information for what
has been happening in the field of data
science and training
uh we're also very proud to announce for
the first time that we are the
recipients of the tober foundation
support a donation that will help us
gather data science bioinformatics
content including training modules
and lectures and we'll disseminate them
through our website through all the
nappy
stakeholders and participants and we're
going to provide the pine bar tech
material for free or through discounted
prices to all nepai members
also we'll be providing cass awards as i
was telling you from different
conferences that we support and we also
will be covering expenses with this
donation for a general lecture on
citizen science which is also very
important
and we'll be covering expenses for
launching surveys and maintaining our
navy website and engaging the nepa
members and organizations into a larger
discussion about how best to train
people especially in data science and
bioinformatics with a goal to
increase competitiveness for biomedical
research
i want to very briefly to also mention
our own program the louisiana biomedical
research network this is the website
here it does have a number of
important information and
recorded lectures on coronal biology and
other symposia that we've held together
with fine biotech
and we also been involved heavily in
summer training this is the previous
summer program that we launched
with over 10 different
types of programs and other than virtual
with the assistance of find biotech and
you'll find this information in the lbrn
website
and we're very proud that we had a
number of participants doing specific
projects as well as virtual projects
through this
i want to take a really brief time
because i haven't seen that
mentioned here that uh obviously as you
uh you'll gather through my presentation
that nih is very much interested in
really disseminating information
and training people the new generation
of scientists in biomedical research
especially data science and
bioinformatics and there's a special
office the nih office of data science
strategy has been created this is the
website here data science at the nhl go
i think very important for any of you
that are interested to really
look at that site because it has a lot
of very important information as well as
free webinars and so on and of course
this is as everybody knows the explosion
of
ncbi data and services is noted here so
the amount of information we are
handling is really humongous has been
noted already and that really
necessitates the need for training
people to be able to
really understand these really large
data sets and be able to derive
information that will help for
biomedical research
so the strategic plan for data science
which is really on that website that you
could download it uh it notes that our
nation in the world stand at a unique
moment of opportunity by medical
research and data science is an integral
contributor so
nih recognizes how important this is and
that's why it creates these programs and
trying to engage the entire country not
necessarily only the top elite
institutions
so this is a definition of data science
in the disciplinary field of inquiry in
which quantitative analytical approaches
processes and systems are developed and
used to extract knowledge and insights
from increasingly large and more complex
datasets
and this is part of the third principles
which is great to create datasets that
are findable accessible interpretable
and reusable
and
you can see all these qualifiers within
the website for the strategic plan of
nih a very important document that
really gives you a blueprint of what nih
will be focusing on the next uh
five to ten years and beyond
so this is the strategic plan for data
science uh it looks into these
components for data infrastructure to
modernizing data ecosystem to data
management analytics and tools to
workforce development and stewardship
and sustainability and the idea program
is particularly focusing uh and nepea's
efforts are focusing on workforce
development we need to enhance the nih
data science workforce expand the
national research workforce and engage a
broader community because i don't think
if we really do not socialize these
tools and information and training and
education we won't be uh be able to
compete at the international level with
other states and countries that are
really focusing a lot on
training their people and competing
at large
with the united states
so um science in the cloud is a very
important uh program the
nih created united data commons
it's as a pilot program and that really
creates access to test data sets
including the national heart lung and
blood institute's transomics for
precision medicine
top net and the nih common spawn
genotype tissue expression so this data
bases are really available for mining by
all people and it's part of really
socializing all these data sets to
everybody who may be interested in them
and one of the more important things
that nih is part of the strategic plan
is citizen science and really serious
science aims to bring science and
science policy processes to the public
to ensure that science is responsive to
public concerns and needs and to harness
additional resources to capture data and
innovation in a wide variety of fields
and a couple examples of
specific
modules have been created the iwire
which is online resource launched in
2012
that challenges players to map the
three-dimensional structural neurons and
you can find more information about that
at dna's website in the experimental
cities and science training for the next
generation program that promotes
biomedical scientific careers among k
through 12 students and aims to increase
participation of individuals and groups
underrepresented by medical sciences so
um it was very uh wonderful to hear
cmu's elite program georgetown
our goal is to be able to really spread
that information and engage the entire
country
and
specifically to the
cloud computing resources uh cloud
computing sources now being available
for idea states 23 states in puerto rico
and minorities serving institutions and
this is the nih strikes program
science and technology research
infrastructure for discovery
experimentation and sustainability and
this is an agreement of nih with amazon
google and microsoft to be able to
provide discounted cloud services and
training
through these agreements and there is
now a
working on understanding what the needs
are and there's an rfi
that will expire
in september to find out
input
for current and future needs and
utilization of cloud computing from
institutions with an idea eligible
states rcmis and msis
part of the idea is to provide resources
to the cloud to a lot of these
institutions that do not have local
resources for computational biology and
there are nih workshops on broad in
cloud computing
the next one is september 13 14 and
there is a website for registration for
all idea
participants
and there are
33 cloud training days
15 by amazon 15 by google then these are
the specifics of the number of students
that would participate
and uh there's a direct contact to nih
for those people that are within those
23 states of puerto rico that they could
participate
so when i leave you with this um
uh this is my
last two final slides i would like to
thought of people uh this quote by uh
harriet pictures stole that common sense
is the lack of seeing things as they are
and doing things as they ought to be
done
we are striving very hard
to socialize
training in data science and
bioinformatics and hopefully will lift
all our communities to be able to be
much more competitive for biomedical
research
and this is the picture of the lsu
stadium football
two few years back when he was actually
full of people we hope to return back to
normancy uh soon and i will welcome any
of you if you would like to visit lsu
to also visit us at the brm thank you
thank you dr kasus
we do have a couple of questions so the
first question
is about members of uh lb rn about
applying to the idea co-funding for r15
uh what are the what is the process for
that
yeah so um typically obviously we assist
in this through our administrative core
um
but
there is a specific um contact person at
the ngms
and um they need to know and
when you are really within
potentially close to a categorical
funding they are you nominated to be
cross-funded by nfgms and the
categorical institute and typically what
happens is ngms and the idea program
picks up the first
year or not 15 or the first two years or
an hour one and then the categorical
institute picks up
the remaining funding
part of the idea is to
allow the categorical institutes to fund
proposals that
did not make the cut uh through
the categorical institute so typically
we've seen grants within
five to maybe 10 percentile points
depending on the topic and the interest
by nih that could get funded um
for these 23 states in puerto rico
okay thank you and another question is
do you collaborate with international
institutions uh for uh research uh
faculty development student exchange etc
yes um
well you know the the home uh unit that
really administers the louisiana
biomedical research network is the
division of biotechnology molecular
medicine
at lsu
a school of dairy medicine that i direct
and we are
sort of uh
working
to export a lot of our training in
collaboration with pine biotech
uh we have talked to a number of
countries we interested in latin america
as well as europe uh southern europe and
quite soon we'll be
announcing
a series of training modules that
are provided right now to only lsu
students internally but we hope to
export
these training modules exercises
potentially a virtual master's degree
to
international students
with a focus in latin america and
southern europe but this time a
potentially middle east and elsewhere
all right thank you very much
and uh final question is uh what do you
think is uh kind of a way for students
without any bioinformatics background so
from maybe a life science background are
there any summer opportunities for them
to join some of this training
so within these 24 states it's fairly
easily easy because all these team brief
programs the idea network of american
sex excellence accept
undergraduate students that within those
states
uh
in louisiana we have 27 institutions
that participate in the summer program
and they apply they get in and
they do summer research
and not only in bioinformatics but also
biomedical sciences by really being
hosted a lot of things the last couple
of years have been done virtually very
successfully um if you're not in an idea
network
um
the only opportunities would be for us
at least to lsu our current efforts to
export this
uh in a larger format
and nebby is interested primarily
obviously for the 23 states and puerto
rico because this is really our charter
to help those 24 states but ultimately
we believe that we could
sort of socialize a lot of this training
because there's a firm belief within the
network that
these tools and training should be
available to people
at very low cost
and as many people as possible as young
as possible because that's the only way
to really
have an inversion point as people say in
business to be able to really transform
education you have to reach out to as
many people as possible and as young as
possible
all right so final question thank you
for that answer
um are there any opportunities for
people working with plant sciences
agriculture and plant breeding uh for um
you know
learning about bioinformatics and
potentially joining research projects
yeah obviously at lsu where the lsu ag
center a number of students participate
in plant related
bioinformatics computational biology
projects
where students enroll at lsu and the
college of agriculture and we have they
participate in a number of our projects
i think it's very possible that we
create
certain virtual projects that relate to
plant science specifically and we have a
number of researchers that are working
on advanced bioinformatics data science
for plant genetics and plant related
projects so you know
data science and
biology
includes both plant and eukaryotes in so
many ways so the same tools are used
across the board
whether it's a plant or is actually
another organism
all right great thank you very much for
this wonderful presentation i'll pass it
on to you to introduce the next speaker
thank you so much ilya and thank you so
much dr uh girls for telling about the
various opportunities that are there at
the lsu now i would like to welcome dr
shindo hits who is a program director
for bioinformatics research program with
the focus on uh health and health
disparities
let
yes
his research interests include
bioinformatics and computational
genomics multi-platform and multi-scale
data analysis and integration genomics
and epigenomics of common health
diseases pathway prediction and modeling
gene regulatory networks as well
knowledge and uh drug discovery using
big data and dr shindo hits would be
giving a talk on bioinformatics and
computational genomics research and
training over to you dr schindler
all right yeah sure thank you very much
for that great introduction and
i wish to thank the pine bio
organizing committee for
allowing us to share
the information about the activities
going on our
lab
so uh i guess i'll wait for dr kasuras
to exit before i share the screen
yes dr shinder you can share your screen
you have the permissions
[Music]
uh i i guess see the screen is not being
shared yet
it was shared and then i think it went
away maybe you can try it
okay
so let's see
so can you see my screen
no we can see your video but we don't
see your screen
okay
what about now now we can yep
okay let me see
all right this is okay now
yeah maybe you need to share the other
screen we see your view not the
presenter view
that's weird
uh so what about this
yep perfect
okay
all right so thank you very much to
everyone and uh thank you very much for
inviting me to share the information
about the
some of the activities that are going on
on the adversary center here
in new orleans
so i'm going to focus mainly on the uh
the bioinformatics and computational
genomics research and training program
opportunities that are here
uh in louisiana i i would like to
mention also that
we are part of lsu just like dr kashmiri
talks about
so we are basically here at the medical
center
that we are in
uh and then a lot of the information
that i provide obviously if you have
questions
uh you are also welcome to reach us
through
uh
you can either call me or by cell phone
or by vocal phone or by
email or any medium that you present and
in the event that you miss some of the
information
you can also just google lsu
bioinformatics and you will find us
there where we have various programs
that i'll be talking about
so what i would like to talk about
mainly is the
uh bioinformatics and genomics program
and i'm going to focus on these
opportunities
under the three
missions of the university the first
mission is the research mission i'm in
the best department with department of
genetics
so research for us
is a commission
we also have research under the service
support which essentially means that
apart from conducting our own research
we also provide other
investigators in the states
and also in the region
with bioinformatics services support
the other part that i'll talk about is
the education mission where we have
various
opportunities uh we have a newly
established master's program in
bioinformatics which is a degree program
which essentially means that you can get
informal training say for example
through pine bio
and then you can also punctuate that
with the
uh a formal training program actually uh
get the degree so essentially for
example paintball will provide you with
a foundation
and then you can come here and have
formal training
and get the
degree
or will basically discuss with time bios
maybe how we can image those programs
there's also a summer program in
bioinformatics which is also which is a
funded program essentially you can also
you can just apply to that program
and the then we will select you if you
qualify
and basically work with us for 10 weeks
and during those 10 weeks you'll get a
paycheck
therefore you don't have to go looking
for a summer job for that
we have the outreach program which
essentially means that we train students
from
neighboring institutions especially
historical black colleges
like xavier demand southern universe and
others
we also have the international program
which we participate in with the various
countries particularly most at this
point mostly with the
african countries
and then we are involved in technology
development which i'll also talk about a
little bit
so
this is a program we have fairly a very
new program and the very few people but
we leverage our
expertise here
expertise in the
at the neighboring universities or
uh with other collaborating partners uh
internationally and in the region
so there is myself and the director
there is dr singing about information
and
there's a deity which he was a
bioinformatics analyst and we taking
bioinformatics as i said uh
bioinformatics and computational
economics graduate students so right now
we have david odof noise from nigeria
which recently joined our labs we have
tarun from india uh and i joined program
with uab
uh the program itself i said is located
at the medical center here
and this is our website
and through this website you can
click on each one of these
put down screens
and you can find additional information
including our publications and all the
activities that we are involved in
we do we do as i said we provide
bioinformatics services
uh we conduct genomic research adobe
cooperative research
and then education and you can reach us
through here
so in terms of setup this is basically
the way our lab is set up
uh obviously when you sit you basically
sit like back to back you don't face
like one direction sit back to back but
our lab is set up this way now the
reason i'm showing this slide means like
dr kasu has mentioned in the preachers
presentation
we do have the capability to collaborate
with partners around the world so we get
data from around the world uh through
various platforms for example
right now we collaborate with
the university of cape town in south
africa we can get data from there uh we
do use the globus platform
that allows us to
uh perform collaborative research and
collaborative data sharing the global
platform essentially means that
we can move data from anywhere
on the globe
uh to our lab using the globus nodes
provided that the other end has also got
the global snort
so if you are working with us this would
be the setup whether you're a phd
student or whether you are in our
master's program or even if you are in
uh the outreach program
so
in terms of research let's say this is
basically the five domains of research
that we are involved in but i want also
to mention that
we are not restricted to human research
we can do any type of bioinformatics
with isc animal sciences
transcendence sciences we can do
uh it's all genetics
and unfortunately
i have worked in both the humans as well
as the animals and plants and so
therefore i feel have
an understanding of
what is bioinformatics genetics
interactive is genetics whether you are
working on animals or plants or humans
uh it's just a matter of semantics so
how you can formulate a question
that you would like to address but these
are the programs that we work on uh in
addition to the listed the three five
programs that i show here you'll see a
green line showing here simply means
that this is predictive modeling
basically where we are using machine
learning and other algorithms uh to
predict different uh diseases for
example
we are working quite a lot with the
alabama genomics
the alabama genomics initiative where we
genotype a lot of people and we are
using genotype information
to basically develop chronogenic risk
scores essentially means that you can
predict the disease risk
of the
eye of an individual
or how to stratify those patients
and that also involved that although
these are divided in quadrants here
we do a lot of data integration in my
lab
that
we integrate various pieces of
information
so that
we can improve the outcome or improve
the predictability
of the
algorithms
by basically refining them an example
would be
uh can you integrate genotype data for
example with the
array music
to
refine the predictiveness of that
algorithm
so
we also develop technologies of course
as i said we support other people other
than our own initiative for research so
we have developed pipelines
these are the pipelines that
uh those who are cooperating with us and
those who need access to that to us
through service support i can access
this so the pipeline that i have listed
here basically they are not all of them
as you know
every bioinformatics question depends on
the investigator but these are the main
ones so we have
capabilities for
our migraine data analysis
and the also genotype data analysis
essentially for microarray platforms
we have rna-seq data analysis pipelines
exome sequencing analysis pipeline uh
genome
for genome sequencing uh we have
recently developed a single cell
analysis time clients
and we have developed also methylation
analysis pipelines these pipelines that
i'm listing here
are backed up by our publications so
that the investigators who are
collaborating with us can actually see
that
we are not only saying that we can do
this but we actually have expertise in
this and those are demonstrated
expertise uh which is very critical as
dr kasuras mentioned that he is very
critical for grant applications because
you cannot just list the names
but they want to see can you actually
do that with their independence that
you have actually done that
as you see these are disaggregated
algorithms here or disaggressive
platforms they are nowhere near where
pine bio is buying pine barrel has an
integrated environment we haven't
reached the uh integrated
environment uh obviously so
but this saves us well because partly
because we are also researchers we are
not only liking
developers of the tools uh therefore
uh our algorithm for example can be
leveraged uh with you say the pine bio
or the tibial platform
so
what do we do uh so these are other
expertise that we have we do a lot of
copy number variation mutation profile
mutation spectrum
and the imitation rates methylation
profiling arrangement sequencing pathway
analysis uh so these are some of the
things that we can do obviously we can
also do some other which are outside
outside the this also for example we go
through chipset data analysis we do a
lot of proteomics data analysis here
um
because we have an actually an active
proteomics core here so
i just wanted to give you a little bit
about
some small demos about the things that
we have done as i said we do a lot of we
have done a lot of genotyping so here's
an example of what we can do
uh so for example we have
uh this is genotype data from 350 000
cases and controls uh basically these
are genotypes people now we don't have
to genotype these ourselves basically we
can get data from public domain for
example this data is coming from db gap
which is basically
rt the nih but it has access so from
there we can analyze here as you see on
the right side here
uh we can analyze basically
mutation progeny mutations
what you see at the top these are single
chromosomes this is just a manhattan pro
manhattan probe
brought to mapping the snips
to the chromosomes
and on the right side here you can see
the low key value essentially we can use
this is the threshold here so basically
we can compare cases to controls and
identify those mutations fortunately
this was what we used to do
[Music]
like 10 15 years ago but now you can do
sequence based uh genome-wide
association studies you don't have to do
genotyping
so for example here is a cartoon showing
exactly what i just showed you before
they are it's just like a tune with
basically different snips mapped to
different chromosomes and the color
codes symptoms for different gene for
different diseases for example uh it
would be cancer
uh hearty disease or anything that you
work on so this is simply aggregating
the snips and marking them to the
chromosomes
and then
we can do this so this means that you
can also do analysis across diseases or
across cancer types or anything that you
are interested or you can use these
resources which are also available to
the nih
website that you can also use these
resources as a reference reference
resources but i wanted to highlight
these that these are the snips that we
are actually using for
developing algorithms like polygenic
risk scores
as i mentioned we also original
sequencing here as you can see we work
very much on triple negative breast
cancer and here basically what we are
looking is sequencing different genomes
of breast cancer and comparing it to
different uh two different types of
nanotriple negative cancer triple
negative cancer for those who are
totally in this area simply means that
it's negative for the three parts for
the three markers estrogen receptor
progesterone receptor and the human
epidemic
receptor growth factor receptor so if
it's negative for that then it's
classified as triple negative cancers
but the basic premise here is the
sequencing of the genomes of
people who are diagnosed with triple
negative cancer and comparing to
determining are there any differences
between the genome the triple negative
genome and the other
genomes so basically you can
work with us on that
and then you can see here there's the
classification of different mutations
different genetic water ratios they
understand the range of base pairs
and things like that so these are things
that you can do with us in terms of
collaborative research again it doesn't
have to be that you work on tripoli
or something entirely different that
will be graduate with you but this is
just the functional based
uh classification of mutations uh on the
left side here you can see the genes
here and different mutations
for example this is we have copy number
variance
point mutations basically like snips
and then simply mapping them if for
example you have exam sequence data you
can map them to the 3d structure and
determine where they're located are they
inside
on top of the surface of the structure
inside the structure backbone or
whichever way
you are studying that becomes
very important for the people who are
studying
drug development
so uh you can also do functional
analysis through that see where are they
located do they actually disrupt the
enhancers or promoters and uh
are they microarray
located in
microsoft actually uh looked at this
problem uh in terms of before looking at
snips where whether they disrupt the uh
alternatives pricing in that
way we have actually published in our
previous reports
we do a lot of uh data integration on a
small scale definitely no way i gave me
a t bio but we do integration of gem
line and somatic limitations so here we
have the german genome that i just
showed and then we have the cancer
genome and then basically we integrate
that information
and then we can look at
for example
the genes which contain germline
mutations also contain somatic mutations
and for example do the pathways that
uh control the german genome also
controlling the uh the cancer genome
this is going to be uh very important
very important as we move through our
predictive modeling where we have to
look at the genetic precision
predisposition versus the uh the disease
uh itself so that's
other than just predicting the outcomes
which we do now uh with the say tumor
data
we may also be used to start looking at
um how to predict the disease risk uh
and that means that
other than focusing on me uh what is now
body uh precision medicine or genomic
racing we may also have to be looking at
the precision prevention for example if
we can predict genetic predisposition
that is thanks to a disease so that's
how we are looking at that we have also
introduced a new dimension to this
rather than looking at the gem line and
somatic imitation we have also
introduced the
epigenetic
data there so for example in this
cartoon you can see here we have gene
expression data here we have mentioned
data
and also the genotype and the gene
the rationale here is basically to
determine
uh where the somatic mutations or
general mutations are located are those
menstruated regions so that is very
important to determine whether
menstruation actually does mediating
the interactions between the germline
genome and the somatic genome so
also as you know
epigenetics is modifiable therefore if
we would
determine that
therefore things like studying like the
biological behavior that might become
quite interesting
in the sense that
they are setting factors that could be
modifiable factors for example obesity
and other mobilities
that can be modified
and how that relates to epigenetic
radiation because we can't modify the
the germline genome but we can modify
the other factors so that's the research
part
so what about the service part the
service by the basically we have various
ways we have the various models
one is through cooperative research mode
where we write a grant together with you
and then basically we are all on the
ground uh the other part would be uh
whether we basically just do a project
based analysis where we say well this
project maybe the investigator says
i don't have enough money so i can't buy
it for bioinformatics see i i i can buy
it for buying but only a small piece and
then it will say okay so this is a
project whereby so for example this
would be pirate studies they order
postdocs and students do pilot studies
they are funded by lbrn or other
organizations and maybe we'll say okay
just so i just say one thousand dollars
for
bioinformatics and that will be project
diversity uh collaboration then there's
a fee for service where i will say okay
i'll just pay you a fee you do the wait
for me tell me how many hours it will
take and i'll do fearful service uh so
in this cartoon i'm just showing that
everybody who does service support know
exactly uh this distraction always
happens the way the information goes
there with their laptop and the
physician on the other side here they
are the other guys so this is still made
there the bioinformatician wants to know
how
what is the objective of the program or
what is the outcome of the analysis and
the on the other hand the physician is
saying tell me how many samples do i
need those kind of things so those
discussions are there so on the far left
here i'm showing that
there's a table here
uh that we have so that is something
that
uh we wanted to collaborate
resolve the program
before actually the project takes place
so that's the corporation we do have
other cooperation here which is the
collaboration with the precision
medicine program which is also here
where we have the information coming
from the physicians ordering the test
and we are doing the bioinformatics
variant calling and giving them the
report card there
and then they can report that back to uh
to the patient so that's the safest part
then we also uh have been working on
using a service but also we do data
mining for example in this category here
we are helping the people to
use the cover genome atlas as a
validation to the
experiments that they themselves
deformed uh so recently we just
published actually a copy the paper
on that from louisiana uh using this uh
genome atlas from uh
from harvard as the
uh the validation
procedure
so the bioinformatics opportunities here
uh we do have as i said the master's
program here is a joint program between
the universe between the graduate school
and the school of mexico
is a two-year program with 10 courses
plus a thesis is a basically project
driven
program
basically it has the 36 credit hours
and the these are the fabric here
so we have the co-fought with pester who
teach that is the basically
interdisciplinary program
i teach
bioinformatics and computational
genomics drought teaches the
bioinformatics programming doctor taylor
metagenomics dr lynn about statistics uh
dr hollenberger dr mundo they teach
molecular genetics again power
statistics here
and also dr guillot teaches things like
he
uh things where compliance
uh then we also in addition to that we
have the program is enriched by bringing
the external that likely dr phillips
says
dr campio said uh so the program is
really enriched by bringing people with
expertise from outside so that the
students don't only listen to us but
they can also listen to other people who
are very well accomplished from outside
for example here dr jonas almeida is the
director of the data science service
center for the mci
uh mohammed tayoon is in industry and dr
j pack from
actual lsu center for computational
biology
and many others that we bring them here
this is basically to enrich the program
and so that students can also discuss
what are the
uh what are the other opportunities for
example under this same program we would
bring someone like dr campio and say
okay can you
for example enrich our program by
telling our students what are the
opportunities outside there other than
what we uh tell them
these are some of the students graduate
students
yes uh sorry we're just a little bit
over time um and uh before we have a
chance to um do you have a a lot more
slides we we have some questions that
people have no actually i'm almost there
okay i think i've probably one slide or
two
here so here are some of the graduates
students who have used our program who
have graduated from our program using
bioinformatics services and some of the
new students here
and this is the summer program here
where there's got all these students
that we have trained under the summer
program so i don't need to spend a lot
of time on this because this information
is
on our website but i wanted to share
with you that actually we do uh these
things and we list where the students
are they have graduated from this
program and where they are now
this is an international program between
us and south africa zambia and tanzania
recently
so we are involved in different programs
they are around the globe as well
i do participate myself in the power net
which is part of the h3 africa
training program and these basically are
the funding agencies
uh and with that uh i should i would say
thank you and uh certainly if there are
any questions i can answer or maybe i
can answer at the end of the program
uh so for being too wrapped uh too quick
on this one that again this information
is available and you are coming to reach
me uh even through dr kasura so through
india you are welcome to reach me in
case you lose my information thank you
very much
okay thank you very much dr um chando
hicks from
louisiana state university health
sciences center so we do have some
questions i think you mentioned some of
the answers already here and we will
connect you to some of the people that
have those questions primarily about
international collaborations so we will
direct them to you
and so nika please if you can introduce
our next speaker
thank you so much elia now i would like
to welcome dr chris taylor he will be
talking on the bioinformatics research
and education for medical and graduate
students dr chris taylor's research lies
in the realm of computational biology
and bioinformatics
specifically related to
applications of high throughput
sequencing this research is highly
collaborative in nature involving the
development of algorithms for analysis
and visualization of sequencing data
over to you dr chris
all right um
let me get my screen share
up
so can you guys see my screen
yes doctor chris we can see your screen
all right great um
so yes as uh mentioned
i am an associate professor in the
department of microbiology immunology
and parasitology at louisiana state
health sciences in new orleans it's the
same institution that shindo who you
just heard speak is from
i also serve as the director for the
louisiana biomedical research network's
bioinformatics biostatistics and
computational biology core
and that that network is headed up by
gus kasulis who spoke just before dr
chendo hicks
so thanks to
the organizers and ilia for inviting me
to speak
and i'm going to just discuss some of
the bioinformatics research and
education opportunities that we have for
medical and graduate students and and
how we
sort of uh address the the issues of of
teaching bioinformatics in a medical
institution
all right so um
i'm actually my background is in
computer science so i got my
undergraduate uh my master's and
my phd in computer science and during
the course of studying my phd
i transitioned into computational
biology and this was a time when
the human genome had was just being
finished being sequenced
and one of the things that was occurring
was that there were a lot of specialists
who were studying bioinformatics and
computational biology and they came from
all different backgrounds so some people
were from mathematics
some from computer science other from
biology who got into computation
and in in that time it was really
bioinformatics was very much of a niche
landscape where there were a handful of
these specialized researchers but
nowadays nearly every discipline within
biomedical research has the needs for
bioinformatics methods and we've really
narrowing this chasm between the biology
and the computing sciences
and i i try to stand sort of in between
the two so that i can um interact with
people on both sides
um of these fields
so
the challenges that that i have run into
is that
as high throughput sequencing has come
onto the scene you know starting in 2005
through about 2008 getting established
and then in the last decade has really
exploded in the in the amount of
different things that you can use it for
because the cost of sequencing come down
so much
there's a plethora of sequencing data
that needs to be analyzed
and
it can't really be served anymore by
these niche
researchers in bioinformatics and
computational biology
so i've found that there's a need for
training biomedical researchers
particularly
to empower them to be able to perform
computational data analysis on their own
data
and those researchers really don't need
to be bioinformatics specialist anymore
they can actually be biomedical
researchers that learn enough to do
analysis of their own data
the problem that arises is really that
these researchers come from a diverse
set of backgrounds some of them have had
no computer programming experience
whatsoever
whereas others have been programming as
a hobby
you know for quite a bit of time
and so the traditional format or
educational programs where you you take
three people through step by step
can end up being in a course setting
too fast for some of the people who
haven't had
this you know experience but can also be
incredibly slow for people who have had
that experience and so when you get one
of these courses
and you have these students with all
these varying backgrounds it's very
challenging to
to do a traditional lecture course
so the emerging solution that we've come
on to and and have partnered with pine
biotech in the louisiana biomedical
research network
is uh more of a reliance on technology
to provide online learning opportunities
which will allow students to move
individually at their own pace if they
can move really quickly through the
modules then they do them fast
and if they need to take some more time
they can take a bit more time and this
is really something that
you can't really accomplish in a
traditional
in-person lecture format but with online
course modules
it allows people to move at their own
pace and so
about four or five years ago i developed
these lecture series that i conducted
and i
i conducted them in person at lsu health
sciences new orleans but we recorded all
of the lectures
using this media site capture technology
and we broadcast them also live
streaming for remote viewing for people
at lsu and other places throughout the
lbrn network
and then there was participation via
group forums for questions and
announcements and distribution of course
material and then we did some quizzes
and tests to
test the understanding of the material
and the idea behind this was always that
these these recorded lecture series
would persist and be available for
viewing on demand and so the two lecture
series that i gave in 2016 and 2017 are
still available
on my metagenomics cert server at um one
of them was a general introduction to
informatics and the other was an
introduction to microbial community
analysis and and these are all available
as slide sets videos
on all the other lecture material is
available in archive
for download at those above urls
and interestingly uh you know some
unintended consequences occurred and i
got an email out of the blue
um from the northern new england
clinical and translational research
network and i guess they had done some
searching and they had happened upon
my lecture series and so they asked me
for permission
to link uh the lecture series for their
own investigators instead of you know
reinventing the wheel and so i think
this is you know one of the very
powerful aspects of the online learning
paradigm is that you can reuse these
materials and and don't have to
continually reinvent the wheel and give
lecture after lecture
on the same course material
and
when we held these lecture series we
also throughout the lbrn network
provided them to our primarily
undergraduate institutes for usage
and um
they could take the lectures that were
recorded online
and then they could add their own uh
sort of lanyapp to them and so this was
done at both lsu shreveport in northern
louisiana and also at southern
university in baton rouge and they
enrolled students in courses at their
own university
and
a lot of them were just topical courses
and then they they allowed the students
to use the remote lecture material but
then the the instructor who was the
instructor of record at each individual
institution
would
partner and would provide
in-person lectures to supplement what
the students were learning
based on their needs
and so
that was
done at those two institutions and then
since then the albertan has partnered
with pine biotech and pine biotech
offers a whole library of courses that
are available online through their edu
platform
and
those are courses that students again
enroll in they take at their own pace
but then they're also if you're enrolled
in the lbr programs
are supplemented with some in-person
meetings that are done online as well
so this address is part of the critical
need for education in in the field of
bioinformatics
and so this pine biotech program it was
initially established in in the summer
of 2018 in that partnership
with pine biotech and the talbot
bioinformatics institute we had obtained
25 educational licenses as part of the
lbrn and we provided them to each of our
primarily undergraduate institution
campuses and they were able to enroll in
the biotech educational modules and take
them and so that pilot program went so
well
that um it's been expanded into a
full-blown partnership with biotech and
the students that take these uh these
modules on genomics metagenomics
transcriptomics and and um other
topics they're encouraged to present
their their project posters at the lburn
annual meeting and other
other meetings that are held a lot of
them virtually now due to the coveted
restrictions
so that's been a large partnership that
has allowed the um you know
kind of expansion of the ability to to
teach bioinformatics
to
individuals who have very diverse
backgrounds and they can go at their own
pace through these course modules so
this is sort of
been a whole evolution over the past
five or six years
and here's just a snippet of the some of
the current offerings from those pine
biotech modules on transcr
transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
and epigenomics and this is all opera
poe to the olmecs forum that we're that
we're going through right now
so one of the other things that i'll
draw your attention to is that
as part of the lbrn
and the uh bioinformatics biostatistics
and computational biology core
that i direct we hold an annual
conference on bioinformatics and
computational biology every year
and we just held our eighth annual uh
conference the actual eighth annual
conference was originally scheduled for
april of 2020
but due to the emerging uh covid19
pandemic we had we didn't have time to
pivot and we actually had to cancel it
so we
we held our eighth annual conference
virtually
april 15th to 17th
of this year
and we have
the
recordings from all the past talks are
available online through the lbrn portal
on youtube
and the links are available at the uh at
the alberin
conference on
biology and bioinformatics
link above
and part of the the meeting that we held
just this year was a session that was
entirely organized a whole day organized
by uh
todd reilly at the uh nih uh center for
information technology
and this was discussing the nih's
strides initiative which is a cloud
computing initiative whereby they've
partnered with amazon web services
research and google cloud research and
they provide training they provide
cloud credits for researchers at angry
institutions
and we've been participating in a lot of
these trainings over the course the last
couple of months since they've been
established
and then we also had other imminent
bioinformatics and computational biology
speakers who covered topics across the
gamut of computational biology
including pandemic modeling
of covid19
the gut microbiome herpes simplex virus
and the role of statistics and
epigenetics research so this is just a
um
a snapshot of all of our our primary
speakers that we held at the 2021
conference and the 2022 conference will
be held similarly will be held in april
of 2022 so
keep an eye out for that if you're
interested um
we're not sure quite yet whether it will
be a virtual format
whether it will be back to an in-person
format or some some form of hybrid
format so we'll see how that goes
so zooming in a little bit um that's a
lot of the initiatives that i'm evolving
involved with on a broader
scale
my own research lab at lsu health
sciences
when i built it back in 2012 i built it
with this open lab layout in order to
promote collaboration so we don't have
you know cubicles or partitions or
anything and i mean that was a great
idea back in 2012 maybe it's not such a
good idea nowadays
but the idea was that you know if
somebody's sitting there working on a
problem and they have an issue they
could turn to the person next to them
and see if they had some advice
and so i always have a mix of different
researchers in the lab at different
career stages i've had post docs i've
had
graduate students i've had
undergraduates through our summer
research program i've even had high
school students through our summer
research program
and even a few
junior faculty members who wanted to
come in
and learn how to analyze their own
biomedical research data
and so you know we work with them and
it's sort of this uh the old proverb of
if you give a man a fish you can eat for
a day but if you teach a man to fish you
can eat for a lifetime so the idea is we
teach these researchers how to analyze
their data and then they they can kind
of spread their wings and and do it on
their own in the future
and so i primarily in my own research i
work primarily with md phd students who
go through both our medical program and
our phd program and it's a joint program
and we just graduated vince maffey he
was an f30 fellow working in alcohol
research looking at the gut microbiota
and i currently have in my lab
jacob elnager who's just submitted an
f30 grant which we hope will get funded
and he's working on
shotgun metagenomics analysis of the
vaginal microbiome with specific
emphasis on bacterial vaginosis
and then i've just hosted for a rotation
a student john lammons who did a
rotation this summer
and likely will join my lab as another
md phd student we've had several past
members of the lab as i said many
undergraduates several phd students who
work with other investigators have come
in and i've helped to co-mentor them if
they have
a project in their home lab that
involves dna sequencing analysis
and so in terms of ongoing research
projects
my research really focuses in heavily
now on the vaginal microbiota and
various sexually transmitted infections
so i have a multi-pi uh
r01 grant that is studying the clearance
of chlamydia
prior to treatment so we have some women
who come in they get tested for
chlamydia they end up positive by the
time we call them back in for treatment
they've actually cleared the chlamydial
infection
through natural host defense and we're
looking at the you know properties of
the microbiome that potentially promote
that natural clearance
prior to antibiotic treatment
we've also got a
a new r1 that's based in south africa
and is joined with the university of
cape town and the university of southern
california
and that's looking at
adverse birth and newborn outcomes and
the interaction of the vaginal
microbiome with
preterm birth and adverse birth outcomes
then there's a an r01 that i have
with a collaborator at uab christina
mosney to study bacterial vaginosis
and my student jacob the f30 that he
submitted is really working uh jointly
under that grant
i'm also a member of the center for
clinical and translational research at
uab uh lsu health sciences is one of the
sub sites for that so that's this ul one
grant
and then we're doing some work on the
gut microbiota and precision medicine
under a uh-2 grant
and we just got a uh an r21 got a
fundable score last month that this is
going to be kind of an interesting one
we're going to look at
transgender men
who are just initiating testosterone use
and we're going to look at how that
impacts
the vaginal and reproductive tract
microbiota and the
propensity for getting bacterial
vaginosis after testosterone use
and then as i mentioned i'm also part of
the louisiana biomedical research
network and more recently we've gotten
an nsf grant funded for a high
performance computing cluster so we're
we're just into the start of the second
year for that and that grant has
supported the acquisition of a a
large computing cluster which we call
tiger fish
and it's one of the fir it's actually
the first high performance computing
that has been broadly available for our
health sciences center campus in new
orleans we've had access to
some of the clusters in um in baton
rouge and through the loaning network
but
this is for
new orleans specifically and it provides
up to 193 teraflops of compute uh 1400
total compute cores
it's primarily composed of these compute
nodes each of which has 192 gigabytes of
ram but it also has available a large
memory node which has up to 1.5
terabytes of ram available
for tasks that really need a lot of
memory to perform their their compute
and so we just rolled this out we got
this cluster in april of 2021 and we're
you know we've got a bunch of users
using it for all kinds of things my
lab's using it cendo is a co-pi on this
grant his lab is using it also carmen
canaver is using it for some
computational neurobiology
and i'm you know in the interest of time
i'm not going to say much about this
because chando covered
the master's program in bioinformatics
that's been initially it is being
initiated to lsu health sciences
and you've already got the link
to that bioinformatics program
and lastly i'll say that i'm one of the
founding members of the microbial
genomics resource group at lsu health
sciences and so you know if you follow
that link
um this is it's essentially it operates
sort of like a core but
we're not really a core so we just call
us ourselves a resource group
and it consists of myself in charge of
the bioinformatics david welsh who's a
pulmonary
medical doctor
and hmong uh who does all of our
sequencing prep and sequencing and then
a variety of post docs and students who
work with us
but we have um on this website you know
we have a lot of our joint publications
and everything but down near the bottom
and and also accessible via this link
is uh you know our cost and our sample
submission so we do a lot of microbial
genomics because we have an aluminum i
seek and so you know we do a lot of
microbial community analysis and we're
just starting to get into some shotgun
metagenomics as well
and so that's pretty much all i have to
say and you know if there's any time for
questions i'm happy to answer any
questions
all right great thank you very much for
this wonderful presentation dr taylor
and uh we do have a few questions that i
think will require a lot of time to
answer at this point we have our next
speaker with us already so what we'll do
is we will
collect all of the questions that we've
had i mean we obviously shared the links
to all of these
programs and labs we do have a page
where all of the speakers are listed out
and links to their websites are there as
well maybe or just for you or something
like somebody could post that link again
uh and uh
with the
time in mind uh sonorica maybe we could
introduce our next
speaker thank you so much ilya now i
would like to welcome dr shamir khadir
he would be talking on pharma and ai
integration of omics and clinical data
dr shamil khadir is a senior director of
advanced analytics data science and
bioinformatics at astrazeneca
a global science-led
biopharmaceuticals company at
astrazeneca he leads a global team of
data scientists biomedical scientists
statisticians and software engineers as
well over to you dr sharma
thank you thank you for the kind
introduction and thanks again elia for
hosting me today
on this
sunday but i can already see that there
are more than 100 uh attendees in the
talk so i know the science is strong
here kudos to you and the team for
organizing such a wonderful presentation
uh from the full meeting let me just get
this
slideshare
okay can you see my slide
yep we can see this line great i just
want to make sure i share the right one
okay it should be fine
okay you can see my slides right
perfect
okay uh yeah thanks again i'm here to
talk about uh two of my favorite things
like about uh you know pharmaceutical
industry in general and also about ai
and then you know in a sense what i'm
going to do today is kind of give a
little bit of a background about why
this is important why is it is is right
now at the moment for these you know
two
sectors to kind of come together and
with the specific example of you know uh
how omix data or for that matter multi
or mixed data
and clinical data that we typically
generate one will be generated in an
experimental setting whereas the other
will be mostly generated in a clinical
setting how and why we need to put them
together so so this is more of a
pedagogical style talk the reason is
that alia and the organizers kind of
mentioned that there will be like a
large number of students attending this
meeting so uh rather than brand new data
what i'm going to share is some of the
published work and then also show how we
are developing some advanced analytic
solutions to address some of the current
challenges in integrating these types of
data using a combination of machine
learning and machine intelligence
approach
so my group's research focus
primarily can be divided into sort of
three main themes like translational
bioinformatics computational medicine
and healthcare data science but the
group my leader machine learning
research group and the focus really is
to is to leverage high-dimensional
multi-scale data to design uh develop
and
repurpose
new therapies that's the single line of
research focus but how do we do this we
are a computational team we are
from the get go leverage advanced
machine learning approaches what we
really wanted to do is we really want to
you know sort of
close the gap between the way we
generate data the way we interpret data
for for many of you who are in this call
is very much familiar that you know the
current era of biology especially i
would love to call it digital biology is
moving at a very fast
scale and and pace but at the same time
if you go into a hospital you'll be
still measured your blood pressure using
a blood pressure cuff that's you know i
don't know 60 or 100 years old or you're
using a stereoscope that's like you know
100 years old older technology but how
can we bring these
two you know rather you know different
worlds together
maybe maybe we could help here as a
group of you know data scientists
machine learning scientists we could
help with the combination of data and
technologies and why why data is
important and you know you might have
heard about big data something called
deep data but for me data at any scale
or any
any grade level range of quality is
interesting whether it's big deep small
or data crumbs doesn't matter as you can
see that these are some of the world's
most popular magazines all the way from
fortune to wired to popular science to
economics and then also two of the
leading science gen they all talk about
data can bring in value but i would tell
you that it's it's not just the data
it's about what question you ask with
this and what tools do you use to mine
this data and then we'll see some
examples as we go forward today and
let's kind of come back from that uh you
know specifically to
uh the setting in biology like for for
example from you know if you want to go
from
a disease for say for example diabetes
diabetes to a mechanism a mechanism to a
therapy and therapy we will bring it to
the patient and then you know a patient
gets a better outcome can that drug be
working for something else and a good
example would be like you know a classic
example would be met for me like that
but then what happened is that we're
seeing a paradigm shift thanks to you
know both the technology aspects as well
as improvement in in biological
profiling technologies as well so there
are like you know both uh the scientific
as well as the technology
is in the incident paradigm shift here
so for example we are moving from a
traditional data type to evolving data
type you don't need to have all of your
data in one location to do centralized
analytics you can now do decentralized
analytics you can go from gbs or tvs in
data to petabytes and extra bytes of
data your data can be structured can be
semi-structured or unstructured you can
use you know nlp text mining and other
types of techniques to bring structure
to your data the data model could be as
tip you know in olden days like i still
remember like when we do health
informatics project we need a stable
data model that's gone that time is gone
now
your data model could be evolving flat
data model data is moving from a low
dimensional to high dimensional and
statistical approaches were you know and
hypothesis-based approaches are now kind
of moving to more machine learning or
deep learning based approaches i'm not
saying one is better than the other but
we can combine these two and you can see
this in studies for example let's take
the same example of diabetes type 2
diabetes you you can see that one of the
first g was had you know maybe thousand
patients but the last g was on diabetes
have like 100 000 plus patients in in
that study so so as you can see we are
we are in in this paradigm shift here
but at the same time you know we also
changing our data source earlier we used
to either a lab will generate a data set
they will analyze that they'll have it
inside or maybe we collect studies like
10 studies that are related and we do a
meta-analysis on that we don't have to
be restricted like that anymore if you
have a good question you can bring in
data from anywhere but there are like
data repositories that are out there
obviously some of them are a commercial
product but some of them like uk biobank
is is completely available for or those
who are interested to ask you know
interesting uh research questions with
that type of data so your bio banks your
biorepositories and then
earlier in the days it was very
difficult to get clinical trial data to
do reanalysis but that is also changing
we now have several projects that tries
to bring in clinical trial data in in an
open access way for example whether
ct.gov or a
aggregate analysis of ct.gov so you can
see that all of that is coming together
and then not just this now we can
measure like
you know typically like you know when we
we run a clinical trial or study when a
patient comes into the hospital we can
measure a few things and then when they
leave the hospital we won't be able to
measure anything anymore but then that's
not the case we now have sensors and
wearables which are affordable and
accessible and can be integrated with
your study program and that brings you a
variety of data as well so you just
don't have to restrict to just the omic
data that you typically measure in the
lab setting you don't have to restrict a
clinical data that you capture in a
hospital setting you can now get into
the real world and collect data from
there so that's that's one of the gist
of the changes that we are seeing right
now and you know this is why this is
possible right now because we see a huge
shift in the technology landscape and a
lot of technologies are kind of kind of
growing up growing together thanks to
access to high performance computing on
and whether it's through cloud or local
or a hybrid approach or you know
advances in you know both the biology as
well as technology like i mentioned
whether it's you know better natural
language processing approaches like you
can mine a large amount of data together
you you can you have you know more
intuitive data models available you can
you can have
a precise integration governance and
security to ensure that the data is
being accessed in a privacy preserved
manner since these are all possible
right now thanks to all of that that
that progress but when we come to drug
discovery development and repositioning
what's all possible so this is a this is
just an example of what's possible if
you bring in ai
into the the whole uh you know
enterprise of developing drugs so you
can you can you can definitely
definitely help in normal therapeutic
agent discovery you can do precision
disease stratification for example
within a population of
who are the disease population within
that disease population what's the
subset of patients that need a treatment
a versus treatment b you can do
integration of multi-homic data which we
will see today and then we can also use
the same type of technology to you know
understand that you know how how
physicians are utilizing the therapies
that we develop when like i mentioned
you know when a patient is not within a
hospital not an ordinary trial we can
still monitor them if they're part you
know using an approach is called
continuous remote monitoring and
diagnostics and then also we can plan
design and optimize our trials as uh you
know using uh ai-based processor so it's
it's so just to kind of give
a broad overview that ai is being
applied across this enterprise of of
drug development
but you know due to the time constraints
we'll only focus
today on the integration of multi-omic
data and we see a few examples on that
and even within within this particular
focus area as you can see that you know
there are a lot of possibilities here
but we will pick three examples like i
mentioned the first two are published
one and the last one it knows it's
that's an ongoing project want to share
and give you an early view into the
project and and you know thanks to our
um
leadership this is you know currently
being developed as an open access
project we'll be talking more and more
about these projects like these type of
community activities and and we'll be
we'll be happy to share the tour with
you all and would be great to hear uh
from you uh you know about the tool in
in
hopefully before end of this fall that's
our plan
okay before you know so that's sort of a
background of my talk so i'm going to
talk about three examples today this is
my first example for those who are new
to the whole genomics genomics clinical
genomics genomics-based drug discovery
this is a quick example
you might have heard about loss of
function variance these are genetic
variants that could lead to an aberrant
rna product and what happens is that you
will end up with a non-functional prot
protein product and this the concept is
there in the literature we have seen
that it's been successfully used to find
targets and and and now been translated
to therapies across the industry in you
know uh that you can see and then the
the key three approach that loss of
function could enable is you can prob
biology you can under if
there is a loss of function that leads
to uh you know variant that leads to if
you know let's say uh loss of functional
protein product would that lead to a
particular phenotype what is its
clinical implication can we use that
approach to develop it therapy these are
the things we can do with the loss of
functional approach and there's a
lot a lot of research have happened over
the last few years but what we were
interested this uh you know work that
i've done uh in collaboration with my
colleagues from mount sinai
the reason was that what we wanted to
know was like let's say if we have
hospital based clinical data and then
also have a biobank that's linked with
clinical and genomic data so what you
have really is genomic and genomic
information and then you know you
obviously need for this type of study
you need an external validation databank
let's hold that for a second and then i
also have data from public repositories
whether it's genotype phenotype tissue
association and then i can also if if i
do identify some significant signal
maybe i can go and test it in an in
vitro testing or in vivo testing
actually so this is this is in a way one
of the workflow that we have generally
leveraged here so we started with a a
database that includes demographic data
this is diagnostic lab test results drug
information and all that kind of comes
from data warehouse and then also you
know more more than 11 000 patients with
their you know
genomic information as well so the
question that we were interested in that
we wanted to understand if there is any
loss of functional variance you know
there are a few already that's been
reported but is there anything that we
could find from our own because our
buyback is a little bit unique on its
own so what i want to understand you
know if you look into these these few
uh you know cardio metabolic traits can
we identify a few loss of function
example so we have a lot of challenges
with that because
we're really handling here with very
messy type of data there will be
incorrect values medication effects and
we used an approach called computational
phenotyping we you know the long story
short we clean the data the data is now
ready for computing and then you know we
did a simple modeling approach gene by
trait association as you can see the
equation and then you know let's say if
i'm interested in a loss of function
variant in upper or c3 the you know
compared to a wild type variant as you
can see that the patients with the loss
of function variant
have a in a significantly reduced
triglyceride effect so that's a classic
example everybody knows that and it has
implications in developing therapies and
all but then we then we looked at a
variety of the like we indeed replicated
some of the you know some of the big
ones whether it's pcsk9 or upperc3 but
we also find something new as well so we
basically like you know kind of
integrated that data like the
the
kind of phenotype data and then did some
candidate association and then what we
did what we identified was
we found a particular variant in
a gene called dga2 could lead to uh you
know in a way
significant lowering in glucose levels
so we we kind of followed that up with
both uh you know experimental studies
and then what happened was that we were
able to find one gene like especially
based on these these these approach with
the validation that you know so our
mouse knocked down studies suggest that
you get you as a potential target for
glucose lowering therapy and we
we have identified a few others as well
let's say for if you're interested in
lowering triglycerides we found
something uh a few genes including rm
rnm tl1 scrn2 pck2 as potential targets
for lower cost so think about it this is
only a small database and it's a fairly
large ehr data but like the linked data
is very small and uk biobank has just
released with hundreds of thousands of
patient sample so really i want each and
every one of the students in this call
to kind of think about what's what's
that you know most curious question that
you want to ask data is never never a
problem like data is always available
it's really how
creative you can be how curious you can
be and then you can ask these type of
questions and you can take it to either
a therapy a mechanism or a target so
that's just my one of my first example
and then the other uh potential theme i
want to discuss and this is again uh so
those who have heard about repositioning
this might be a little boring for those
who are hearing this for the first time
repositioning is an approach where we
take an approved or or a drug in insert
drug or a therapeutic in a certain stage
of development we take that drug we see
we investigate whether that drug could
work for any other indication and like
you can see in literature a ton of
examples like that and then
what we can do is like if you could
identify that using
a drug that's an advanced stage of
development you know that could could
potentially be developed into a therapy
for a new disease so we could
potentially save some development years
and then also uh the cost time and
energy too but at the same time you
still have to repositioning is not just
not just a computational part but you
have to do
downstream analysis downstream uh
clinical trial but the time to trial is
where we are going to save actually
rather than it's not like when we hear
about repositioning don't think that
it's an experimental approach where we
do uh completely in silico that's not
the purpose or the aim of repositioning
you can do that but really the value
will come when you take it to a trial
and then there are a lot of different
ways to do repositioning and one
approach that we've been focusing on
this type of a molecular match making
approach using a a you know one type of
data here this is primarily
transcriptomic data so we we can
generate what we call as
drug signatures and this is signature
and the idea is that you know using uh
you know statistical learning approaches
can we identify a you know let's say
this is the disease signature for let's
say you know disease two and i want to
find a direct signature that could
reverse these these red to green and
maybe this is a good good candidate for
this particular disease so can you do
that type of a molecular matchmaking for
that and then we were interested in
repositioning and did one of the one of
the largest meta-analysis in the space
and what we found and i want each and
every one of you to think about this
and tell me your thoughts also when we
looked at around 200 or so
200 plus repurposed agents
across 1100 diseases what we found when
we did a post-hoc analysis
these three purposes let's say i have
drug disease one and disease two and
they that can be potentially targeted
using drug x they are more likely to
have
shared genetic architecture for 31
percentage of them more than 31 we saw
that and then again around 27 percentage
we saw that that's those two diseases
when you look into the the pathways they
share we saw pathway crosstalks we
quantified them and then the most
interesting part just like you know by
integrating the molecular data with esr
data what we or clinical data what we
found was
if two diseases are comorbid we see the
most commonly within a patient
population they're more likely to uh
potentially be repurposable this is not
a hard and fast rule for it but again
you know the there is there is some
evidence that's coming in these are the
areas where you should potentially look
when you when you're planning your
infrastructure investigation and why
repositioning works because one of the
potential reasons representing work is
because it's a it's you know clear
trophy platoon is a key biological
phenomenon you know and and where one
gene could influence two or more
seemingly unrelated phenotypic traits
and that might be the reason why you
know and then the genes are doing
different functions in different
settings so when you put using you know
one drug against two diseases maybe
there is a better uh targeting strategy
there so just for you to think about it
and as an example so we recently you
know this is again a work that we've
done at mount sinai so here what we did
was in collaboration with my friend and
colleague uh kamela shadow who's now at
texas a m
and what we did was we're interested to
come up with a therapeutic strategy for
a rare uh form of prostate cancer so we
we did some public data analysis
identified some gene expression data
from geo and then uh we basically run
our repositioning algorithm we were able
to identify you know some of these uh
some of these drugs and then what we
found was interestingly
an alkaloid of course that naturally
long uh black purple called a compound
called pipolitamine was doing really bad
good in our some of our viability essays
and when we looked into the literature
and we saw that you know this is this
could be a potential target because
there's there's already been a ton of
data on this in the literature so we
went ahead and built a mouse model for
this unique sort of rare cancer type and
was able to show that you know the the
drug indeed have uh have an effect as
well so so really like you know this is
again one of the example i wanted to
share with you and in a similar way
if you're passionate about a particular
disease of interest i would highly
highly encourage to include
repositioning as a potential strategy in
your in your research
so the last part that what i want to
cover today is we live in like we have
seen that like we live in a world of you
know data in flux and we we have uh you
know this challenge of you know uh
we have more data is being generated but
there is a huge delay in inference from
this data what i meant by that is let's
say my friends and colleagues in
microbiome or you know genomic sciences
or trans you know
or multiple mixed groups generating
these different types of data they know
what their microbial signature is
related with associated with the disease
they know their their genetic variance
they know their transcriptomic signals
but they never they and they interpret
them independently they never put it
together and look biology in a more
connected way but biology actually
operated in this level it's an
integrated approach but what can we do
about it and on top of that forget like
along with ohmic data we also have like
custom as a data a company like
astrosync for that matter any other
pharma company will have some custom
essays imaging data phenotypic data
clinical data you name it and then
instead of analyzing them independently
can we analyze them together this is a
question that's been you know
really
been challenging for us and just like
the the entire industry here and uh when
we
started our group you know one of the
first group that reached out to us our
microbial sciences group reached out to
us and asked a hmir can you and your
team help anything with this and i was
like really happy because there's going
to be ton of data on this you know we
can we can apply some deep learning
approach and then what i realized was
interestingly the sample numbers are
always very very small and then you have
this classic uh you know analytical
challenge where you have small n and a
large p
and then what happened and then we did
an extensive search in literature survey
and identified that you know why we
cannot really use single techniques and
then you know just make a bigger or
better version of that
but they do not take you know
statistically into the you know
integration aspect and then they do not
find relationship between the omics so
what we realized was maybe we need to
make a list wish list of these omix
approaches and then potentially come up
with a way
that we could you know then we used to
um you know uh in
integrate analyze and interpret these
data set so what we thought was okay
let's let's write our our wish list here
so we started with this sort of wish
list and we what we found was there are
three key ways that you can do ohmic
data integration you can do an early
integration you can do an intermediate
integration or you can do a late
integration but then what happens was
that it doesn't matter what you know
what type of integration you you choose
we also want to make sure that the data
represented in each of these you know
data or omicronomic type
should be equivalent one anomic should
not dominate you can still wait to your
or mix if you want and they should be
generalizable it should not be only work
for you know transcriptomic or ngs based
techniques or it should only work for
imaging based techniques and then we
need to do variable selection on each
block and then you know in in a way that
we have to also do predictive modeling
on top of that and and two of the key
part was like you have to understand the
relationship between in different types
of formics and then also
you know it should not be confined to
only ohmic data but other types of data
should also be able to add and then you
know we we came up with this approach we
did an extensive literature survey and
then instead of developing something
brand new what we thought was we start
with the within with a pretty decent
package and then add features that
doesn't exist in it so we basically
start with something called diablos as
you can see that we have some objective
and subjective classification approach
that we took here and then you know we
identified certain algorithms that could
go in there and then with that
on top of that we have built some
additional layers as well so these are
the key features we can do a lot of
normalizing and scaling within our mix
world you can do single single ohmic
multivariate modeling you can do
multi-ohmic multimedia modeling you also
come up with a new
strategy let's say you've done all these
analysis then you can actually do what
we call as a block crank and identify
the best features from that and best
model and it's more stable model and
then you can go do downstream
experimental validation as well so so
this is in a way i don't have time to go
through everything but what i can do is
this is a sort of a broad overview as
you can see here we have a lot of you
know
different types of ohmic data can be on
border once you do you know
pre-processing and then you can do two
types of analysis or rather three types
of analysis you can do if you don't know
the class label you don't have a class
label it's fine you can do unsupervised
exploration if you understand what's
your classes you can do supervised
exploration and go all the way to the to
the modeling part if you want to
do you know cross data set prediction
you can build models whether it's random
forest so you know support vector
network you can do that so and then in
addition to that we have uh other models
that we're building towards you know
understanding the gene sets and
repositioning and all of that as well so
this is in a way what we want to do here
really is to
address the challenge in this biological
data interpretation problem so the
features are interpretable three things
if you have to you know take take away
from my toxic interpretable features
relationship between omic tapes it can
be inferred and it's scalable to add
neonic types we have done so far done
integrated with 12 types of data and we
strongly believe that you can add more
types of data as well so this is a quick
example like this is the dummy data sets
that we have put together so you can see
we have
control zero positive and
and disease uh for for a cohort and then
this is uh our initial model we do model
selection and tuning models get better
do better separation the first one is
using the this one is using monomic data
and this is using multi-ohmic data you
can see that and in addition to that we
have
an array of novel visualization
approaches you can also understand the
stability of these models as well here
and then
this is what's available we will be
sharing this with the community very
soon
and watch this space
and with that you know i would like to
come to the summary uh i strongly
believe uh you know biomedical
healthcare data science is is is it can
actually optimize accelerate reduce the
cost of development as you've seen
a lot of examples today and i'm sure
you're seeing hearing a lot more
examples throughout this this symposium
and as data scientists be ready to push
the limit of your
comfort zone it's a team sport right
like we all all need different types of
idea to push the limits because we don't
know what we're going to find that's the
joy of
being a data scientist and then the more
creative you are you know the good
handle of subject subject matter
expertise that you have you can
definitely bring in a lot more value
and then you know definitely biology in
biology everything is connected it's
important to ask a bigger and bolder
question
and one more thing we are always hiring
always looking for collaborators and and
uh will be uh you know
potentially looking for interns and and
um apprenticeship positions and all
looking to feel all of that so please be
in touch you can find me on linkedin or
twitter and we'll be in touch uh
if you would like to connect and we'll
be happy to stay in touch
and you know i would like to acknowledge
my my team from seneca and for the other
two examples from the team from
mount sinai and with that uh i'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you
great well thank you very much for this
great talk and uh a couple of questions
so first of all a personal question how
did you personally end up at astrazeneca
and uh kind of can you briefly describe
your path
oh i'm sure yeah so
uh
yeah in a way
uh
i wanted to be a software engineer when
i was you know from from straight out of
my high school thank you for asking that
question so
and then
but i took biology for my high school so
in india i'm originally from india in
india you cannot really go to computer
science uh with the biology background
so you have to do some kind of an
undergrad in in a non-biology background
and then go to computer science so and
then i i went to an undergrad in physics
and then when i was doing physics second
year or third year of physics i heard
that there is this subject called
bioinformatics that combines
uh you know uh computer science and
medicine i'm like wow that's fascinating
that's really really exciting thing
and then um
i wanted to get into a master's in
bioinformatics so instead of going to
computer science i completed my master's
in bioinformatics and i did my grad
school from india under professor
sadamni like national center for
biological sciences
and i worked primarily on building
machine learning models to understand
protein sequence structure and
interactions
and then i
i one while i i did that work i wanted
to kind of get experience with other
type of data and that prompted me to go
to mayo clinton for my postdoc
and i was trained with this whole ehr
based data genomic it was in the
beginning of the whole uh sort of
genomic medicine christian medicine
phase in the us which we were one of the
first site for
a project called emerge electronic
medical records in genomics like 12
years ago and was part of that
participated in several clinical trials
and then uh eventually switched to
industry uh you know it's at a certain
point been doing uh some consulting and
eventually switch to industry and uh i'm
with az for now three years the reason i
joined az three years ago az was
starting the data science group and we
were like only uh maybe like you know my
my including myself and my boss we were
like three members now we are around 60
and uh now now the whole data science
and ai is actually 150 plus in natural
seneca so we have grown a lot and and uh
really really excited to bring
you know to see the power of you know
data science and ai
in in drug discovery so this you know i
still remember
you know in one of the early days of my
my master's in bioinformatics i hear
that we are going to see precision
medicine every hospital will have a
bioinformatics team which is something
i've seen happening right now you you
can see that ngs is in every hospital i
mean like in one way or the other the
physicians are using that in like one
way or the other so so we're really
there i mean like this is our moment and
uh um yeah so that's that's the long
story in a short way thank you
all right great thank you for that uh so
okay so we do have another question um
you uh mentioned that you
did your postdoc at um
mayo clinic and uh how different is it
working kind of in basic research as
opposed to
you know clinical type information i
mean how uh how different is the
thinking and you know the need there in
terms of omix data
so so definitely like you know in uh
compared to the uh compared to the basic
science group where we
we primarily work with you know genes
proteins and computers that's where
that's what we were working on here you
have patient data too but at the same
time you have to think about what is
patient data in the end what you capture
in an ehr data is nothing but
think of it like a
large long experiment
right like you know you are you're
measuring biomarkers you're measuring
imaging data you're measuring other
types like you know medication data
these are all different types of data
that you measure from your patient
cohort that's being compiled into
you know
not always a user-friendly database you
always need to do a lot of processing
because there's a lot of human errors
because this will be either typed in or
or translated by a you know an automated
transcription engine you have a lot of
clinical notes that you can mine through
so so there are a lot of a lot of that
pre-processing is required but in the
end the way that i thought about that
was you know this is pretty much like an
experimental data but it's coming from
you know a physician and patient
encounter you know and and that's how i
kind of thought through that and now
what we're seeing that we you know when
we were at back at mayo the the
challenge was to put genomic data into
electronic health record we have
achieved that you know it's there and
everybody's aware and we still need more
training we still need the accessibility
is not global we need to improve that
all of that is for true but
now the field of the experimental
biology is moving at much faster pace
and as you can see that like you
mentioned biology is now more digital
biology and we have that gap they're
generating more and more data
we're not able to interpret them on time
so how do we do that and that's where
approaches like omix fold and you know
these these kind of strategies and
need needed and again we cannot do it by
ourselves we need collaborations we need
to work with the community and and and
and i really appreciate this invitation
to kind of share our research with you
all
great thank you another question uh so
while recruiting for bioinformatic roles
in astrazeneca is a phd an advantage or
should you have only a master's degree
we we have you know i can i can speak
for the group that i am part of like
what we are data science and artificial
intelligence so we have
a senior senior data scientist principal
data scientist and then as assistant
director as a director senior director
and the executive director all the way
up to the vp is that sort of our career
level in data science we don't have an
absolute requirement for for for a pst
so if you're very good at you know
in in some of the technical skills or
scientific skills have
you know a passion to work on solving
the type of problems uh that are related
to drug discovery development and
repositioning or even in the under and
their enterprise of
of drug development including clinical
trials or patient recruitment we we we
hire you know both both phds and masters
it's a it's not just you know um
even we have undergrads too like
a very few undergrads too
okay perfect so we are going to be
starting our panel here in just a few
minutes
right before that and thank you dr
carter for your insights we're going to
continue with the panel so please stay
here
but before we jump into that we want to
briefly summarize what we heard up until
now we have just a couple of minutes to
do that
so let me uh do that i'm gonna
share my screen
and i did want to mention that dr carter
mentioned omix fold
just as you were speaking we posted a
link to the github repository i don't
know if you have any other links you
would like to share
you know maybe you could post them in
the chat and our team will make it
available to everyone
and i will just briefly again summarize
and hear what we have heard from all the
speakers up until now and then i'll pass
it on to
mohit to introduce the panelists
so
the first speaker that we had
was professor sima bhatnagar
from amity university the assistant
director of the biotechnology program
she really talked about her research in
india in
precision medicine in cancer some of the
work that her group was doing on
computational analysis of different
proteins and interaction with different
precision treatment drugs to avoid
adverse
effects of other treatments but she also
spoke about the biotechnology program
that includes bioinformatics at amit
university and how students can get
involved especially
the programs in india but also
international programs for international
students
with the possibility of
also attending the campus in the u.s so
that was a great talk that we
heard first we then continued on to talk
about a different type of a program
which is
a program for master degree students
uh professor sona vasudevan the director
of systems medicine program at
georgetown university medical center in
washington dc uh some of the things that
they are doing in research in terms of
systems medicine
so obviously
what we just heard from dr carter as
well
basic research
biotechnology programs and then medical
challenges and kind of
issues that students have to face she
also talked about the kind of sustained
interest and increased interest in
machine learning and how we are working
together on addressing that problem in
her program for the students
we then talked we heard from dr philip
compil
who's the associate teaching professor
and assistant department head at
carnegie mellon university one of the
most exclusive programs for
computational biology in the country
here in the us
very difficult to get into but a lot of
opportunities for those that are
persistent and are really looking to
acquire
coding computational algorithmic
development kind of skills so again a
very different flavor
again of bioinformatics and
computational biology but
very important to kind of understand
what are the perspectives and
opportunities they also have
high school programs for high school
students to have a summer experience
understanding how algorithms can solve
real biological uh challenges
and some of the interesting projects
that they're doing in microbiome
environmental microbiome as well as uh
kind of interesting work that they're
doing on uh code 19.
so then we went on to hear a message
from dr gus casullas and he is the
department head at louisiana state
university but also the pi of louisiana
biomedical research network and the
president of the national association of
idea principal investigator
that really brings together 23 states in
puerto rico
it is hosted in baton rouge in louisiana
where his primary role is
but he is essentially responsible
for kind of overseeing the
implementation of some of the idea
programs
around the country
helping elevate biomedical research and
providing opportunities for students
over 50 000 students to learn about
bioinformatics learn about
data sciences which is of course one of
the mandates for nih and nigms which is
funding
this whole idea program with over um 300
million in research
funds
we then heard from dr chindo hicks who
is a professor and program director
at the department of genetics at lsu
health sciences which is a
[Music]
kind of a center focused on genetics
but also working on multi-omics
integration working on health
disparities
and one of the highlights i think from
his talk was the
interactions that they have with
international students especially with
programs in africa and so we have a lot
of students
from
african countries that are looking to
kind of continue their studies continue
to phd programs master's programs they
do have a master's program here
but they also do a lot of collaborative
research and so i think a great
opportunity to hear from them about that
program
we then
heard from dr chris taylor
who is a professor of microbiology
immunology and parasitology and the
director of bioinformatics biostatistics
and computational biology core
for the louisiana biomedical research
network and um you know he shared a few
very interesting uh aspects of his work
directly on microbiology related
metagenomics analysis
as his background is also in computer
science and kind of coming into
bioinformatics from that perspective
he also provided
interesting insights into the needs for
high performance computing in a lot of
these larger studies
and some of the exciting projects that
they're working on related to precision
medicine and related to also training
and education that is being made
available widely through the louisiana
biomedical research network
and directly from lsu health sciences
center
and then finally we heard a great talk
from dr carter uh he's the senior
director of advanced analytics data
science and bioinformatics at
astrazeneca uh it's a really interesting
i think overview of
computer science
oriented programs medical type programs
and then basic research programs around
different countries
sorry around different locations in the
u.s last
day in the previous day on saturday we
heard about other countries
and we did hear today from amity
university which is in india
but i think this talk brings us
to the topic of our panel discussion
and
really highlights some of the important
similarities and differences in the way
that bioinformatics can be used across a
variety of different domains
and
without
much further information on what we've
heard i think all of these talks were
really exciting and you know a lot of
information for us to digest but at this
point i would like to pass this on to dr
mohit mazumdar
who is going to be introducing the panel
speakers for today and i do want to
mention uh before he does that
that we do have a full list of speakers
with the links that we
have received from them
you can find all of this information
on this link
one second i will put it for everyone
okay so if you go to this link
you will be able to find all of the
speakers from yesterday and today and
the links to kind of
learn more about all of that so over to
you dr mazunder
thank you
yeah
now
uh i would like to welcome
everyone to
this much awaited panel discussion focus
on bioinformatics in industry
so
today
we have uh we are privileged to have
some of the leaders from
bioinformatics and biomedical industry
involved in uh pharmaceutical industry
assisting in
modern drug discovery so our first
panelist dr samir khadij is a senior
director of advanced analytical data
science and bioinformatics at
astrazeneca a global science led by
pharmaceutical company so at astrazeneca
he leads the global team of data
scientists biomedical scientists study
statisticians and software engineers he
oversees the profiles and portfolios and
projects in oncology and biopharma to
accelerate drug discovery and
development using biomedical and
clinical data
and machine learning approaches so we
just heard from dr shami sharing
insights
from
pharmaceutical prospective in applying
bioinformatics especially putting
emphasis on data and the technology
applying data science and envisioning
artificial intelligence in the
pharmaceutical industry along with dr
shamir we have mr sarun walia currently
at mit selected as prestigious uh salon
fellow uh he
dr mr saroon is a biotechnologist by
training and uh and with a broad
experience
in
areas such as biotechnology consultation
over 14 years and then
worked across three different continents
he is an expert in business strategy r d
planning and pipeline strategies his
work also involved in marketing and
branding strategies in pharma and
biotechnology
our next panelist is mr anthony finbo so
anthony finnevo is the ceo ceo of eagle
genomics and has achieved success over
many years as a ceo of technology
businesses he has occupied every seat at
the board
table chairman ceo cfo nxt and
investor director for both public and
private companies and now assists
leaders and their management teams in
meeting and overcoming the most
significant challenges that they might
uh encounter on their journey
in the panel mr finbo will share his
perspective on different aspects of the
gap that he sees in academy and industry
in bioinformatics and the vision he has
built
to build an ecosystem with students
faculty partners around the world to
advance the bioinformatics or
biotechnology platforms that enables uh
eagle genomics uh
as a company
uh next uh it's an absolute pleasure to
introduce mr nahid fuji uh nahit koji is
the president and ceo of cyclica a
toronto based biotechnology company that
leverages artificial intelligence
computational biophysics to reshape the
drug discovery process so cyclica
provides the pharmaceutical industry
with an integrated holistic and
end-to-end
platform that enhances
how scientists design screen and
personalize medicines for patients and
has recently been named by deep
knowledge analytics as top 20 ai in
pharma companies globally nahed is also
co-founder of the alliance of inter
artificial intelligence in healthcare
aaih
of which naheed is one of the four
appointed executive officers so he has
been featured in global mail
forbes vanity uh woopsie insider and has
been
invited
faculty in uh in many universities
describe
discussing topics in such as ai in
medicine
so i welcome you all uh here and before
we go into the actual discussion and
begin the session i would like to give
everyone a maybe a brief overview of
how
things have shaped up and why we think
this session is so important so from
genetics and toxicology to microbiology
to radiology there are
i mean the different branches of biology
to specialize in
and out of many bioinformatics is one of
the intruding is one of the intrusion
fields which enables us to identify
evaluate store and retrieve biological
information right something that we have
learned throughout this
omics
symposium now integrating the elements
of data
so when it comes to medical uh research
and or product development data science
refers to a broad uh rapidly evolving
field that supports the analytical
process of extracting
knowledge from a variety of data sources
and types right and then integrating
data types and resources such as uh this
omics data types like genomics
transcriptomics proteomics phenomics
image
images and variables that the data that
we get from there all of this actually
this gives us a holistic understanding
and identifies
in identifying the most meaningful
interferences that leads to the best
decisions so big data in biotechnology
is in today's world is not just only
about genomics but it's also about the
data that may be collected by sensors
variables ingestibles or implantable
sensors that can provide this continuous
data stream for clinical clinical health
clinical trials so in biopharma industry
the focus has now shifted towards
processing data more
effectively and deriving uh relevant
insights to realize its full potential
so by working together different
analytical methods offer this holistic
pictures and translate this into
practical steps for product development
maybe marketing or maintenance
strategies so uh with this overview
i would let the panelists to take this
forward and
share some insights on how
uh uh the future bioinformatics
and data science uh that they envision
and that they see with experience and
the best approaches that you may have
figured out from your own experiences
so
i would like to invite first uh
uh dr shamies to share his thoughts on
this
thank you mohit i really appreciate that
great great background and great
overview and thank you
fellow co-panelists and
in my opinion uh you know we are we're
seeing a uh sort of a transition in in
in our industry especially in
bioinformatics industry and i'm also a
bit uh
a little bit concerned about that too
because everybody now calling it you
know data science and then you know
either biological data science or
biomedical data science and we've seen
that also like like you know we have
seen that even even in the evolution of
bioinformatics we have seen that too
like it has gone through certain cycles
but now now we are we are in a stage
where
uh you know a bioinformatics person
should have definitely the domain
knowledge domain expertise you should
know his tools databases and all but on
top of that you know having that edge in
ai machine learning and predictive
modeling are going to give them
a better access to jobs positions and in
internships in my opinion so that's
that's where where i'm i'm thinking and
then the other
potential uh observation that i have is
that you know
the data science on abroad is you know
is you know there was a harvard business
review piece saying that it's one of the
hardest career in in of the century but
then again so calling it a biomedical
data science is actually good but but
remember you have us you have a
particular edge because you are trained
in this domain from the get-go so that
that that would be my thought i would i
would invite um
anthony to kind of comment on his
observation in this in this theme
thanks shamir thanks mohit and also
echoing shamir's comments delighted to
be
participating alongside such a deeply
competent panel here uh amongst whom i'd
say i'm the interloper um because i
didn't and don't have a background in
bioinformatics um
i'm a serial entrepreneur
uh i'm an interloper but i can claim
some substance and knowledge because 30
plus years ago
i did my studies in cybernetics control
engineering and maths
and uh you know that's deeply
information theory uh related
and i have to say i was delighted to
discover only quite recently that claude
shannon
who's godfather of information science
i discovered he did his phd in genomics
uh i don't know how many of us knew that
uh but um
it was a delight for me i felt slightly
less of an imposter um but i i come at
this from a very different perspective
so look i'm an entrepreneur i've built
uh four or five companies over the years
and uh in a number of industries
and i've either listed those on the
london stock exchange or the nasdaq or
sold them to us nasdaq listed buyers and
i i entered this industry about five
years ago
and mohit i'm just fascinated to see
how radically understated the size of
the market you projected there on your
initial slides is um i mean i actually
came to this space because of the
tremendous innovation opportunities and
uh you know i'm just following most
recently the guidance provided by
mckinsey and company uh
uh and by boston consulting group
henderson institute the research
establishments that those consultancy
firms have developed um
towards industry 4.0 which it's
increasingly clear is going to have a
very significant bio dimension to it
mckinsey and company describe it as the
biorevolution
and uh to participate in the
biorevolution boston consulting group
henderson institute describe the
opportunity as nature co-design
and so you know my perspective on the
market is very much bigger than just
drug discovery
it is application of bioinformatics and
data science technologies to enable
customers to participate in the
biorevolution
and to that end we at eagle genomics are
building a company a platform company
to
enable microbiome science networking of
microbiome science in the first instance
because we perceive that to be the most
proximate battleground if you like in
the
bio revolution
now um just particularly to the question
i think uh a lot of my frame has been
shaped by what i've done over the last
uh
20 years in telecommunications industry
uh network uh
network uh um software for
telecommunications industry
twenty plus years ago that industry was
radically disrupted by the introduction
of
tcpip
and internet protocol before then it was
time division multiplex networks and
the
two-bit code
internet protocol disrupted that
industry first slowly then incredibly
fast what happened in the early stages
of that disruption was that
big companies the big incumbent telco
companies tried to build groups of
people that understood internet protocol
and could build the technologies to
exploit it
and that's what i call first generation
uh you know dynamics in these
enterprises
as the market evolved we started to see
best-in-class applications coming from
external vendors
and more of a focus on the underlying
business from the telco operators and of
course our industry here the industry
we're all in some way participating in
has is being disrupted by the 4-bit code
dna
and uh first in the early stages we're
seeing a lot of companies experimenting
evolving
their capabilities
uh to exploit that uh understanding of
dna
human animal uh microorganisms et cetera
but i think what's clear to me as an
outsider is that um
and and i'm not alone in this uh
observation you know the dirty secret of
data science 1.0 is it's not scaling and
it's not scalable
and in order for the industry to really
evolve
data science 2.0 is required
and that's a kind of blend of
informatics and data science skills with
enterprise class technology
and so what i'm trying to do and what
we're trying to do is
fuse
enterprise class software skills with
bioinformatics skills data science
skills to create this opportunity to
scale applications that we can promote
to large enterprises that want to
participate in the bio revolution but
also to network research establishments
so that we can enable collaboration
between between the the players in this
in this bio revolution and i think
that's liberating tremendous opportunity
for
people in the bioinformatics uh industry
i think the bioinformatics career path
is evolving really really quickly i
think it has to have and it's incumbent
on us to infuse entrepreneurial skills
as well as technology skills in the in
the in the in the students and the you
know researchers that we're cultivating
for this biorevolution
and i see nothing but just incredible
opportunity in that regard
thank you uh dr anthony and thank you
mohit and shamir i can go next uh
i'm tarun walia i'm a biotechnologist by
training as mentioned and
for the last 15 years i've been working
at the cusp of
biotechnology commercialization as well
as data science
and i agree with a lot of thoughts that
you both have already put forward and i
believe the opportunity is high there
are a few things that i really advise a
lot of people to focus on
is uh you know going multi-dimensional
uh but
what i mean by that is
um for years the data science has been
studied in a very different way from
what biomedical or pharma or discovery
has been studied in now bioinformatics
is a field that of course ties up the
two but uh there are still so many gaps
which are there and which you know you
come to know when you're speaking to a
core
data scientist who's doing machine
learning or building ai models and when
you talk to a research scientist and
he's more willing to do those mouse
models and the research right so how do
you tie up the two
is is there a way where you can
if not an expert is there a way you can
understand both areas really well and
then tie it up with the
commercialization process by
commercialization i mean is
where where do we have a window of
opportunity for a drug therapy to be
there or a diagnostic to be there so
just having the commercial acumen tied
up with the data science test and tied
up with the research side is something
that i really want people to focus on in
the future
and i will finish off comments so nahid
kergi it's such a pleasure to be here
today and to listen to and join uh this
panel
um you know
i'm
also not a scientist so anthony there's
two of us and i'll consider myself an
interloper as well and my background is
historically in finance and strategy and
back in the day i spent a lot of time in
humanitarian aid
before then coming back and making a
contribution back to the life sciences
which is where i believe the most impact
can be had in
uh in humanitarian work is how do we
make
medicines and make those medicines
available
broadly to
people all over the world and how do we
think about data balance data fair data
the availability in the application of
that data in the pursuit of medicine
secure diseases many of which are so
ranked in areas of the world where there
are patients who may not be able to
afford the prices that exist in western
or more european societies but still
have
uh desperate needs and so that's where i
spend a lot of my time and uh it's a
pleasure to be here today you know when
i saw your opening remarks
moment in that one slide where you just
showed the growth of i think it was data
it reminded me vividly of
the growth of the protein data bank
now a little bit about cyclica we are a
quote-unquote ai for drug discovery
company and in today's environment we
designed small molecules
to interact with desirable proteins and
avoid undesirable anti-targets or
proteins that you'd want to avoid for
toxicity reasons or for selectivity
reasons
and so for us right now as a 60-plus
person company with offices
across the world
our strength on the r d side is in
structural biology computational
structural biology computational
biophysics
and
if you go back to linus pauline and the
determination of the first protein
structure i think that took him
approximately 22 years
to deposit that first protein structure
into the pd what is now the pdb an open
source repository of all protein
structures add in that was back in 1948
it took him a lot of time and then in
1978 the pdb became available and if we
look at from 1978 to about 2013 when
cyclica was formed
there was a
fairly exponential
growth in the total number of protein
structures that were available in the
pdp when we started there are about 95
000 protein structures that represented
give or take
20 to 30 percent of the entire proteome
that 20 20 30 of the genome today
181 000 in a span of seven years it's
doubled
there's more structures being deposited
um
increasing our knowledge of biology
increase our knowledge and availability
of things to prosecute and when you
couple
that which i will say as an asterisk
that was before alpha fall deep mind
released their alcohol to code and have
now made available essentially the
entire proteome across 20 species and
over the next few years hundreds to
thousands of species before all that
there is this exponential growth of data
so when you take the availability of
proteomics data
genomics data transcriptomics data
clinical trials and real world evidence
data you have a mast an availability
unlike any other time in history on data
but the most important thing that we've
been thinking about is not the amount of
data but the quality of data
the representation and the fairness of
data and then also how to use that data
in a thoughtful way to solve real
problems not just to take data to solve
any problem
and so for us it's abstracting the
problems that exist in biomedical
science truly understanding
um that
you know bifurcating it truly
understanding the problems that exist
and then matching the data with the
algorithms and then with the advance of
cloud computing whether it be gcp amazon
azure and now with nvidia and how
strong they're getting into the
biomedical science space with gpus and
then what's the coming down the pipeline
of quantum and compute uh quantum
computing and so for us it's how do we
take all of this available data
take cloud computing take algorithmic
development whether it be machine
learning or deep learning and start
asking ourselves questions of what's
possible and what are the problems that
can be solved
and so for me as a non-scientist by
classical training i've spent a
inordinate amount of my time
studying and spending a lot of time with
people at the interface of those three
areas and at cyclica when we look at the
team of students that we have brought in
some straight out of
bachelor's degrees mscs phds post-docs
people from industry were living within
the intersection of experimental science
computational science and then
humanities do they have the deep empathy
to go and seek out those problems in a
very new way
and so i'm happy to kind of talk a
little bit about how we've built a team
we're going from 60 to about 150 over
the next couple of years and what types
of skills and experiences we are looking
for and what i encourage students to go
seek
in the pursuit of what is the biggest
opportunity which is the making of
medicines
thank you everyone so really good
insights and i wanted to jump in here
and kind of uh you know direct the
conversation towards uh first of all you
know i will start from something that dr
carter already mentioned as a biology
interested student going into computer
science and then finding himself
at the end in this career of
bioinformatics or data science
and kind of picking up on some of the
other highlights that all of you agreed
on that really industry is not just
solving any problem like the heat set
but specific problems that are uh you
know the real quote-unquote problems uh
to be solved right so there there
definitely exists kind of like a gap i
think from a student perspective on what
does that look like right and so hearing
about all of these exciting topics
addressing medical needs you know
bringing better medicines to market uh
maybe solving some real scientific
challenges
how do you envision somebody that is
still a student or an early career
scientist uh kind of understanding what
exactly you know when you envision this
big machine of 150 people working on a
particular problem or you know thousands
of people working on another problem you
know how how can they uh kind of uh see
their future uh using bioinformatics
some of the problems that your companies
are working on so maybe i can start with
uh anthony
what do you think about that
well it's um you know each and every
company is despite um
you know the opportunity we all have to
research um
uh at our desks uh you know every
company is
by and large a black box and you can
only glean so much about a company from
the outside
and i think it's incumbent on us to
therefore provide
structured paths for individuals that
can know only so much that are competent
capable that you know are increasingly
sought after resources is incumbent on
us to create the pathways for them
to
explore and then specialize you know
after a period of time within the
organizations that uh that we're
creating
and i think um
you know i i uh by the way uh you know
another thing i'd say about myself just
quickly is that i i left school and did
an aircraft engineering apprenticeship
but i ended up
fulfilling my boyhood dreams really
early as a radio radar engineer on
concord the supersonic airliner um
and and then i got fired because uh
british airways which was the company i
was working with uh got privatized
but i look back to those four years
where i just learned horizontally across
a huge number of domains before i
started to specialize as
formative in my
uh career as an entrepreneur
and as someone who's able to do things
and so we're trying to instantiate that
apprenticeship structure apprenticeship
program within eagle genomics we're
working closely with universities in
cambridge
to
develop and deliver
uh
what's described over here in the uk at
least as a level 5 apprenticeship
so that people can explore they can
attach to individuals that are experts
in a range of domains
they can be mentored by these people
they can discover their core skills and
they can recognize where their strengths
lie and therefore where you know they
ought to put their energies because
we're great believers in
strengths based coaching identifying
what people are you know cut out to do
unconsciously without uh you know being
burdened by doing it and then vectoring
them towards that path so they can
really exploit their skills i think
that's one of one of the things i'd say
the other thing i'd say is that um
you know the field is moving so
incredibly fast that uh you know one has
to look forward as well as backwards you
know the technical when i when i talk
about backwards i mean the technologists
that are available today to learn you
know they are going to be evolving so
quickly
that um you know one shouldn't be
worried too much about specializing and
one should be open-minded about um
you know how to evolve in the future
what i'd say also about you know the
focus we have is that we're
you know in in much the same way as
nahid has described his business we are
trying to
network microbiome science so we're
using uh network science as the kind of
fundamental fundament on which to build
our platform and our business um
delighted to say we we
we we
raised series a funding last year and we
managed to get one of the leading
thinkers on network science laszlo
barabashi to invest in our business
we're about to raise a series b
round of funding
um but i think um uh what i'm trying to
describe is a picture that's highly
fluid in the early stages so that we can
attract the right resources provide them
with a framework
uh such that they can
learn broadly and then specialize deeply
and i think we we have to offer that
kind of career
path to individuals lest we try to get
people you know too focused too quickly
great thank you so uh dr carter would
you like to add to that from your
perspective
sure thank you yeah uh
you know it's an interesting statistics
i want to share with this group actually
over the last year i might have
interviewed more than 100
you know quote-unquote data scientists
you know sort of junior to senior level
role
and then also been leading some of our
internship in a program global
internship program and we recruited
um more than 15 interns over the last uh
six months but we received more than
800 applications
right like you just you know just think
about it like you know and then for each
and every one of you who are students
and trainees in this group how can you
differentiate
and this is just you know one company's
one department you know looking to fill
a few internship decisions
and that particular position uh the one
where we got 800 was actually
for a u.s based unfortunately this was
only open for us based graduate students
you know there are like certain country
requirements for some of these positions
but we received applicants applications
from everywhere in the world which is
okay now unfortunately we can hire all
of them
and then the you know and then when i
was going through that whole process you
know whether pre-screening screening and
that you know finally interviewing a
sick you know uh
a lot of candidates we had you know we
finally hired our interns actually
they're about to finish their projects
and all
what i wanted to kind of tell you is
that what what what was that quality
that you know led to that final offer
you know from from my perspective right
like they were you know it doesn't
matter you know the you know in an
interview and that's the traditional
interview process where you send an
application you you know you review the
cv you know you bring them in and then
you have a face-to-face interview but
then that first step is to to select
your cv so it's definitely important
what you put in your cv so if you're a
student
make sure that you have some kind of a
project based learning
be you know whether it's you know
putting extra time with your professor
or collaborating with another friend or
working at a company that's you know
straight across your university
go ahead and do that that's as important
as your coursework i know schedule is
stuff and you know right now we live in
a pandemic world we cannot really go in
in irl that's not possible but then you
can reach out to them send an email make
sure that you have that trust so one of
the the factor that stood out for these
applicants were they had some kind of
experience and then
then the question would come from
students oh that means we we always have
to have a project to get to an
internship no that's not the case you
you can still be doing you know uh uh
undergrad in anthropology and want to do
human data science that differentiate
you just like what naheed was mentioning
right like you you bring in a different
perspective to the group that's also
okay
and then the other part is when you come
into the interview it's your
communication and clarity it doesn't
matter whether you worked on i don't
know the the predicting seed properties
or you know you you worked in
identifying how to launch satellites it
doesn't matter unless and until you are
able to give your elevator pitch in like
you know three minutes or so we all have
you know
if you take humanity itself our our
attention span is reducing right like
you know we all have that issue uh if
you if you think about the most leading
social media platform right now is stick
talk and average time a length of a tick
chocolate is 15 seconds
so we are living in that world so you
have to have that you know 50 you know
your elevator pitch ready you have to
have clarity and communication and then
you know and then let's say if you hire
you what matters the most it's not maybe
it doesn't matter whether you are the
the world's one of the world's best
machine learning scientists or
programmers these these skills that we
talked about you have you can
communicate clearly you can you can have
good engagement with your stakeholders
in an industry perspective whether it's
your group that you work with you either
your line manager or the team that
you're working with and then also making
sure that you understand
the change management aspects that you
will bring into the table what i meant
by that is we just you know whether it's
you know stakeholder engagement and
change management this might be new to
many students here because traditionally
we don't teach
management or strategy to our
science stem based i mean ste based uh
programs of course m if it's mathematics
or management depends on that
but stakeholder engagement is how do you
how do you deliver your project in a
refined and in sort of a very much uh a
pre in a predefined way and make sure
that all the deliverables are met within
your within your schedule and then you
need to have some kind of a direct
communication line with your all your
stakeholders of the project who either
funded your position or funded that
project and then what's change
management let's say you're building
this beautiful algorithm whether it's
for you know small molecule prediction
or or to identify a cancer patient
subtype who's going to use that
algorithm will they use their algorithm
are they going to trust in that
algorithm what baseline did you use did
you communicate that of course with the
stakeholders but also
with your users if you don't have a user
a million multi-million dollar
investment in ai is not going to have
any benefit
so these are the things you have to
think about right like of course your
science and technology skills and
scientific and technology skills are
important i'm not saying that they are
not important but are you able to
communicate your idea clearly are you
ready to engage with your stakeholders
are you ready to have this dialogue to
do change management
these are important skills and this kind
of carry forward you know it doesn't
matter whether you're an intern you're
coming as for a full-time role or you in
your leadership journey throughout this
this this segment of this particular
industry this matters a lot so
the long story short version of that is
you know to make sure your your
communication and clarity that's going
to be the number one skill it's not your
python programming or you know how to
run single cell sequencing i mean like
they're good they're great
but
are you able to interpret and explain
your result to your lab to your group to
your collaborators that matters a lot
right do you mind if i jump in and just
provide
a perspective from a small budding
company not an asd company i agree a lot
with what shamir said in in
overall remarks but there's a couple
nuances as
students are thinking about applying to
a earlier stage company
um and then a large pharma and i will
say az and cyclica done a lot of work
with astrazeneca and paul agapow is a
close friend and shamir i'm sure in the
data science group you've worked with
paul and you know we've done some and
published some work with aaz in the data
science space but here's what i'd like
to say to students who are thinking
about applying to earlier stage
companies
generally when you're applying to an
earlier stage company a seed stage
typically five to seven eight people
series a eight to twenty thirty forty
people and then beyond depending
especially in the biotech stage that's
usually where they line up
if you're applying earlier on
i would highly encourage
you to truly know
the entrepreneur or the co-founders of
the company listen to and read what
they've been saying in the marketplace
and understand what that company is
talking about and match your
views and visions to that and what can
you do to augment
because there is going to be whether
you're a co-op
an intern or co-op an employee and a
contributor going into a management role
that becomes a very important role for
that company and have a group of dozens
to hundreds of applicants
they're going to invest a lot of time
reading through each one at cyclica at
each stage we've done
hr with students well at some points in
time we've done it poorly at some points
in time but what we've continued to
invest in is the
um is the student marketplace
we have rolling co-ops with the
university of waterloo university of
toronto we brought in co-ops from
northeastern university where we have
the office in boston that's something
that we pride ourselves heavily in
and then we've continued to disseminate
content through what was previously
called aia my homework an online forum
where we talk about everything from
target selection to clinical development
and how ai is playing to roam we'll have
our team and then external folks come
and talk about that generally made
available to high school and university
and graduate students
and so this becomes really important but
what i'd encourage as you learn there's
all this material that startup companies
disseminate to that market to build
their brand
don't make it an application that is
cookie cutter
because that company is differentiated
they're they're fighting every single
day to differentiate themselves so it
behooves you as an applicant to say how
you're differentiating yourself and how
you and that company are going to help
differentiate
and so a i've seen far too many just
you know application that you can take
out the name of cyclic and replace it
with any other company
and that loses traction in our eyes
because
we are going to in the information age
of 15 second tick-tock videos
we fight against that fallacy and we
instead encourage all of our hiring
managers to read everything
and as we go through reading that
information it come becomes abundantly
clear those who are just applying
because there's a job application versus
those who are genuinely interested
in earnestly joining cyclica and the
last thing i would say is that there's
two types of applicants there are those
who
are deeply immersed in the subject
matter of bioinformatics or
computational chemistry or computational
biophysics whether they be
uh you know third-year undergrad
students or graduate students or
post-docs those are the ones that had a
directionality to their educational
experience and they have clarity
generally as to where they want to fit
and then there are those who are
anthropologists who want to bring a
human element to shamir's point
highly valuable but maybe they went down
a different career path educationally
but now they want to make the leap i
have an undergraduate degree in
psychology and organizational behavior i
spend time in finance and strategy and
somehow i've joined
and co-founded an ai and drug discovery
company and now i'm the ceo of this
company so there is merit in the
non-classical approach
we have hired musicians
as data scientists who then self-code
learn to self-code we brought on
musicians to help on our design of our
user interface for our internal and so
it really becomes how do you tell your
story depending on your directionality
of your career related or unrelated if
you are genuinely interested in joining
that company your brand is the sum of
all experiences that a person will have
with you so you've got to make sure that
as quickly as possible but as
consistently as possible you're able to
tell that story as to why that company
should choose you
uh tyrone would you like to add anything
to that
sure i think uh my panelists uh had a
really strong point so i'll just keep it
very short but i i think shami put up a
fantastic point when he said you need to
differentiate your application
or into different differentiate yourself
and
there are various ways i have seen
applicants differentiate i mean
some of them really use social media
really well and by social media i mean
linkedin like you know putting your
yourself out there and and sharing the
work you've done
it can be small research but uh
positioning it how it can have an impact
in the long term or how it can add value
to the company that you are applying for
um another thing that really works well
is
understanding the company that you're
applying for not all companies are the
same you may want to keep different
resumes uh some are focusing on say
oncology you want to focus what you've
done in that area some are focusing on
say cardiovascular you cannot have the
same kind of research for both
um
it's again points to differentiate
yourself because if i'm reading
something where i'm working for an
oncology company and someone has that
experience yes he'll be weighed slightly
higher
and
of course it doesn't mean that you know
you have to know everything
what it means is how you can position
yourself for that role that yes you are
the person for this job
and then uh the other point that both
naheed and shamir put forward is on the
teamwork side of it i think i would love
to have a team player on my team
so someone who can work well with others
and there are ways you can distinguish
or you there are ways you can uh
focus on in the in the interviews and in
the overall process
and and someone who can show that impact
even if he's not done a lot of research
but is willing to learn and willing to
make an impact so i think these are
certain ways where you can really
differentiate yourself and that's the
key point i would take away from the
conversation
thank you i think it was it was amazing
that we all discussed all of this
because if i have to summarize there was
so much value in all of the
conversations that we have had it's
really difficult to summarize all of it
but i do have a few points that i would
want to highlight here so all of you
being
leaders
and
being able to do a lot of training in
this
manner where we are talking about
integrating other players into our team
and then it requires uh to have that
sort of understanding where i mean this
process is like get simpler like it
should not be more complex uh then and
then it becomes challenging so what i've
heard from uh
shamir is that like uh there are some
skills and
that that that is required but there are
some other soft skills also which are
required so
at times i think it helps to think them
through and
have a strategy or like
think about the things that could happen
and that coin kind of you know vision
can comes from this sort of
understanding where you are telling that
these are important things that we have
to consider so i think that is that
gives us a lot of value to the students
who are listening here and maybe
thinking that okay maybe this is a x
scenario and if i have to put myself in
that x scenario what are the different
outcomes uh different people different
thinking
that i could address while being in a
group
while being and being a team player so i
think it requires a lot of thinking in
that context and
uh being able to understand
about the company i saw that like one
thing that i would wanted to mention
especially for a big pharma or like when
we would want to
understand that what is actually going
on there so the difference like what we
see in research labs many times we kind
of look for the pi and then we find the
articles and then we find that the
methods that they've been using it's
really kind of
easy for a student to
investigate further about a research lab
and
look for the pi and go for like an
internship or something like that but
when it comes to encompa to a company um
the
the openness uh there is is limited
so i mean
for us to understand that how
bioinformatics differs in a company
versus a research is a gap or is also a
challenge
so dr shami what do you think about this
yeah sure uh so you know there is
nothing like a perfect candidate right
like we we always have there is a human
element to hiring for that matter and we
don't expect you know everybody to know
everything and within our data science
and ai group we have a significant
section of our group is actually
dedicated to learning and development
so you will bring certain skills to the
table but additional skills whether
let's say you have some background in
statistical modeling but you want to
learn computer vision we will have
courses or we will immerse you within
the team that actually doing computer
vision day in day out so we we need to
make sure that you come in and then you
can build your uh you know
your technology portfolio your skills
like that so that's always possible in
in a you know in a formal company like
you know in a company like ours or other
other players in the industry as well
and then um the the other part is like
you know what we have to understand here
is
you know
if you take bioinformatics as a whole
like what some of these parts of
bioinformatics will we will do
internally some of these would be done
by cro some of this would be done by
other types of companies you know that
like you know uh smaller companies that
are actually hyper focused on that
particular type of analytics and then
what you will do internally might be
still at the bleeding edge so you have
to get ready for that it's going to be a
little bit different
then a traditional academic setting
where you will keep on analyzing or
develop improving your pipeline we
because we need to move move the needle
we need to push the boundaries because
anything that you do right now is
actually like you know if you are in a
more r d focused role it will be you're
potentially contributing towards a drug
that would eventually get developed
five to ten years down the line
so you're working backwards right like
you're not going to get an fd approval
you know in this year or this month for
you know for for an rna stage molecule
right now so you you will basically
contribute that to working towards what
could happen in five to ten years and if
each and every one of us think about
where bioinformatics was five to ten
years ago versus now
you know we can literally see it growing
right like you know whether it's access
to high performance computing or more
algorithms more methods we see that so
so we just be future ready just be ready
to sink in and and if you know that's
what i would say and go with an open
mind what that was uh tyron's point
right like you know if you're good at
good at certain skill whether it's you
know whether it's writing communications
you know social media or or even as
simple as making videos
have a catalog of your work somewhere so
that we can see that we can we can
understand your your your skills okay
you bring insert something that's that's
unique and then you want to come in and
and become a data scientist or or or
running pipelines like this this this
can be done that's for sure and one more
last point i could i could make here is
that
the industry is seeing uh an influx of
career in this space right like you know
and he also mentioned about this
we we have uh you know uh initially it
was just data scientists now it's data
engineer data
data engineer data is there's two
separate roles now we have you know we
used to have you know devops to support
the whole development team now we have
mlobs ai ops now you know down the line
you know five years when i don't know
maybe there's a bioinformatics or i
don't know i'm like so there are new
things that would eventually evolve
and you can shape up your career towards
that so be open and one advice that i
could give to the students is that just
because
you know you have strong biology you
doesn't code don't think you cannot work
in in bioinformatics because we need a
lot of analysts
we need a lot of people to do
biocuration we need a lot of people to
validate the algorithm we need a lot of
test engineers so there is nothing like
okay a
good bioinformatics job means you know
database programming and advanced
machine learning no it's a you know it's
fundamentally it's communication writing
skills you're you know like i said you
know stakeholder engagement you know
these are these are the skills and on
top of that be good at one thing whether
it's programming whether it's genetics
either it's
curating variance doesn't matter there
is always always an opportunity and and
i personally don't believe
even with influx of all of these
advanced machine learning or applied
machine learning someone who's doing
this for
i started doing it in 2002 maybe 2001
it's going to be 20 years i've seen that
applied ai in biomedicine for the last
roughly 20 years
you know don't worry algorithms are not
going to take your job don't worry about
that you you know don't worry about it
it's good to have that good algorithm
development skill but we still need
curators we still need uh developers and
engineers and all so yeah so that would
be my take on it those are some
fantastic points uh jamir i would love
to like uh add a bit here
and uh you know one of the things i also
see when people transition from research
to the
corporate side is the i think the people
succeed when they are able to relate to
what makes the company succeed
for instance
when you are in doing your research your
focus is on okay let me focus on this
particular aspect of the value chain and
you forget the downstream value chain
and the downstream is your clinical
development your commercialization and
bringing the product to market
where you can help patients right so the
more you converse with your counterparts
downstream like talking to clinicians oh
how how do you decide the end points uh
what patient segments are we targeting
how is this research adding value
downstream and then also talking to the
say the commercialization folks like
what is the patient need uh uh and and
then you know just having that dialogue
with your colleagues across the value
chain that really helps when you're
entering a company from the research
side so yeah
and if i may just to
pick up an amplify on what tyron has
just said there and
my experience is often that with people
transitioning from science to industry
that they are very focused on
the um
you know the the ground truth and the
approximate deviation from a ground
truth um
and uh sometimes and most often in an
entrepreneurial environment certainly
building a company there's a lot of
ambiguity
and huge amount of abstraction is
required to be successful and you know
perhaps this is most simply
characterized with fixed versus growth
mindset i think what tyron's saying you
know the people that are successful in
reaching out to understand downstream uh
the shape of what's coming those are
people that are required to have this
growth mindset i think you know to
really benefit in the future that is a a
key attribute i'd say
i don't have too much more to add and i
want to make sure that if there are any
other questions we can go to that but
the only thing that i would
close out with is
know what you don't know as well and go
seek out that knowledge
um education is the best competitive
differentiator um
and it doesn't have to come through
classical means coursera edx
there are so many different you know mit
with the sloan management they have and
the relationship with coursera i have no
affiliation with mit i've just taken a
bunch of courses and i have four more
lined up for the rest of the year
you know
within the company or outside of the
company just continue
to see trends that you like
follow some and then create your own and
the only way that that that's possible
is through a continuous education
and b application and testing those
things out in the context of what works
what doesn't work and continue to
iterate you know you can't call yourself
a ml scientist a data scientist if
you're not willing or able to daisy and
update your own mental model based on
things that are happening in the
industry and so students just continue
to
whether you're high school student
or you're 65 years old and looking to
get into a new industry or myself which
continue to try and learn and stay ahead
of stuff
just continue to educate
so thank you everyone this really kind
of like what i heard some of the things
and i heard very different things you
know so anthony mentioned they have an
established apprenticeship program with
a particular university and i'm
imagining you're kind of trying to build
that out further
and then uh you know shamir mentioned
that he has
interviewed a lot of
applicants from around the world there
are specific positions and specific
skills that they're looking for but
there's a lot of this corporate
structure on top of basic skills
and then i heard also from
and
you know as a smaller company how
important it is to kind of realize the
vision and kind of align yourself with
that vision and kind of highlight how
you can contribute to that and grow and
continue and expand and then uh tarun
also mentioned how uh you know
understanding the domain and kind of
like showcasing what you have done in
that domain is very important so that
brings me to this question of
relationship with universities uh you
know you you can obviously build your
own ecosystem right you can participate
in research and showcase what your
company is doing in that space
but in many cases you know students
don't come from nowhere right they're
already a part of an ecosystem they're
already a part of something that
they've been led to believe or to kind
of envision themselves right and those
examples that they have in front of them
and the pathway that they've went
through that kind of shows them what
they might be possible you know might be
able to achieve so my question is really
um you know how can universities prepare
students for careers
that you see in industry
specifically for companies that hire
bioinformaticians or from those
backgrounds
you know how can faculty at universities
how can the administration at the
universities
potentially work with companies like
yours
to establish that pathway and kind of
provide that future for their students
i can take that one first if you'd like
um i don't come from a research
institution so for profit but we have
at the moment uh relationships with over
220 research institutions globally as
part of our cyclica academic partnership
program
and we open up in its acronym cap to
work with academic and research
institutions for two reasons number one
we make available our computational drug
discovery platform available to
uh pis principal investigators within
those research institutions at no cost
to them
in the pursuit of advancement of basic
science and the translation into
potentially commercial viable
assets that could maybe one day become
drugs and the second and most important
reason is to build brand recognition
with the next
wave of
uh students and researchers who will be
trained under those pis and they become
available into the marketplace
eventually whether they be at if big
pharma companies like az
genomics companies
like with anthony or they continue to
remain within academia and
and then become a pi themselves how do
we help train or affect behavioral
change in the minds of uh many
scientists on what is possible with
computational approaches both
bioinformatics physics based ai machine
learning deep learning
um so we think a lot about that and
we've instituted that cap program and
it's been highly highly successful then
there's another type of relationship and
i'll point to a few examples i think
boston
does this exceptionally well
and so i'm sure tarun will talk about
how
and i'm not picking on boston again i
have no affinity i'm canadian but like
boston has done this exceptionally well
stanford has done this exceptionally
well i think stanford i saw a release
recently in the past 24 hours where it
stated that over the past decade they
started 680 companies and the total
market cap of those companies is close
to 20 billion or 50 billion dollars or
something like that just from startup
companies that have come out of stanford
and so what does that then mean that
generally means is that those companies
are created with
brains that have been educated in those
research institutions that then go
translate go raise venture funding or
funding from other environment strategic
partners
go translate that research
hire people create
uh actual economy and jobs generally
from the ecosystem as the term was used
and probably likely from their academic
institution that they came from and so
there becomes this virtual cycle of
training educating and then deploying
into the marketplace and there are a
couple areas in the world that have done
this really really well i i think canada
and specifically the beltway between the
university of waterloo and like mcgill
university in montreal have done this
very well especially at the intersection
of experimental sciences like biomedical
scientists sciences as well as
computational and computer science ai
etc
with the university of waterloo being a
very very strong school at that frontier
and right at the epicenter is the vector
institute in toronto and then mila the
montreal machine learning institute in
montreal and what they've done is
brought in the hospital networks the
research institutions with industry and
government funding to not only train the
next wave of students but to provide
them with the basic
pillars to enable the commercialization
or translation of that research into
partially viable entities and so you're
looking now at where is the next
frontier of innovation yes absolutely
boston with mit and harvard and
northeastern which is really coming up
uh and then you have in california but
you have a lot of
small little sectors that are growing
globally and that point to what's
happening in toronto and in canada uh in
our space that's probably the vectors of
influence pointing there
yes thanks
um just echoing
the model that nahi described you know
what we're trying to do in networking
microbiome science is connecting the
leading research establishments that are
driving the art and the science
with the enterprises that are seeking to
exploit that um
we focused uh not so much on drug
discovery in the short term although
that's increasingly part of our
focus but helping
industry participants in
nutrition and
food and nutrition
cosmetics and personal care and ag bio
to
network understanding of microbiome
science into their models and on our
platform connecting the research
establishments with the enterprises so
they can collaborate with us if you like
as the glue in the middle around some
particular projects we're also
often sponsoring phd students within the
end within the research establishments
we describe them as knowledge partners
that we're working with and we have we
already have quite a highly distributed
business we are
in cambridge in the uk in the centre of
london kings cross what's called the
knowledge quarter next to the alan
turing institute the francis crick
institute google deep mind
we're in manhattan in the new york
genome center in potsdam on the potsdam
science park
in paris in microsoft's ai factory and
also in hyderabad where we have 30
people already so we're trying to create
local partnerships with research
establishments because we want to foster
relationships and
you know encourage candidates from those
research establishments to come through
to join us but it's really important to
us that we are
creating clusters where humans can
interact with humans not if in this you
know quasi-virtual world in which we're
we which we still inhabit um
it's not necessary to be uh together
with uh you know a mentor or whatever
every single day but it's absolutely
germane to our
evolution and building of our business
that we afford people the opportunities
to interact with other humans on a
frequent and regular basis so that's
driving our model
um and maybe i could ask actually to
ruin to answer next and and together
with that if you could kind of address
this question uh how do organizations
deal with converging business
uh in scientific rigor so business uh
kind of you know interests and
scientific rigor together without
damaging either
wow that's a tough one
um so you know that's that's uh
there are a lot of
conversations around that you know how
can
we have best of the both worlds and uh
make sure
that the research we are doing that's
one hand and the commercialization that
we're doing that's the other hand and
how can we succeed by joining both hands
right
and uh often the often the trick here is
communication
i mean an open communication where you
know you you you're empathizing with the
other party that yes i understand what
you're doing uh not blaming the other
party if there is failure failures are
bound to come the failure can be from
the research side it can be from the
business side and
then i think that's where uh the role of
the ceo and i think anthony and naheed
can vouch in there as well
how can ceo play that role where he he
showcases that yes the business side is
important as well as the research side
and and collectively is when we win so
so making sure that the whatever
activity we are doing by activity i mean
it can be experimental research it can
be understanding uh
what is happening from a clinical
perspective and also understanding what
is happening from the business
perspective and and and mentioning how
all of these tie up together
and uh
and
and i've seen that you know sometimes
the business perspective is that hey i
know what i'm doing i don't need to
understand you are a researcher you
don't understand this business so so
just just aligning both parties there
and it's a good question uh because
often it can be detrimental for the
organization so so what what worked for
me when i was working in this area was
having sit together with both parties
together and somehow being that bridge
that can help communicate because you
need to understand both sides of the
business to be a good mediator here and
and i think i would love to hear even
naheed anthony's perspective here
because as ceos they are doing it day in
and day out
tyrone if i may just go directly to that
you've just pinpointed the
primary job of the ceo both internally
and externally is to be translator
and modulator of information delivered
from different sources speaking perhaps
you know all english but fundamentally
different languages towards a common
goal and i think at this early stage in
the evolution of our industry where we
are bringing together uh individuals
from backgrounds uh educational
backgrounds and um you know experiential
backgrounds
to a particular focused endeavor from a
range of different uh environments
translation is is the core skill and
that's the other reason by the way why
we're so focused on this uh
apprenticeship approach because we're
trying to create the mechanisms to
enable people to understand
the voices from the range of sources
earlier in their careers because they
get too siloed particularly perhaps you
know most often with phd uh postdocs uh
you know very focused uh and and uh
without the sort of constant
perturbation if you like uh that
forces the individual to explore
the broader environment beyond the core
focus um that becomes increasingly
difficult later in a career
yeah um not much again
you're getting
uh front-line seats to some very
thoughtful perspective
there's not much more i can add to that
but i don't also want to remain mute on
this important topic
i would say unlike
any other time in history today there's
a convergence of skill sets based on a
bunch of stuff that now exists that did
not exist even 10 years ago again i go
back to the availability
of high quality
a lot of high quantum and relevant data
that is
when
trained with new algorithms like ai or
ml deep learning what have you and
powered by
uh new infrastructure cloud computing or
even that which is coming down the
pipeline you now have this convergence
of opportunity
and so unlike before where chemists used
to talk to chemists
biologists used to talk to biologists
clinical scientists used to talk to
clinical scientists you're now seeing
pharma
generally over the past number of years
create an environment where these people
are sitting together sharing ideas
and therefore incubating
converged approaches so med chemists
aren't only talking to med chemists
i think novartis has come out and
actually led the charge in terms of at
least how they branded themselves
whether practically i have no idea but
they brought chemists and biologists and
computational folks sitting together
and so as i think about that model and
vis-a-vis cyclica
we have internship programs where we
bring on biomedical scientists
bioengineers computational chemists but
then expose them to different areas
within the organization so we have a
group of applied scientists which is
what we call them there are drug
discovery hunters med chemists organic
chemists biochemist biologists folks
that have lived at the bench to do a
bunch of stuff
but who have a propensity towards
computational techniques or data science
techniques
now whether or not they trained that way
as part of their
education formal education where they
did it on the side
what we've brought in is a group of
people who are really curious about not
doing it the classical way
and so i would continue to encourage you
know the company that you want to join
are they able to offer you that whether
it be through formal training or
apprenticeship programs like anthony's
company
we do very similar tag teams bring the
teams together and make sure it is
interwoven and not separate but then i
would continue to encourage the group of
students here
no matter where you are in your career
to continue to seek out that level of
information
bolt it on to the thing that you spike
in the most what you do and what you're
most passionate about but continue to
add on to it and from a company
standpoint make sure that they're able
to fulfill that curiosity that they're
able to scratch that curiosity itch for
you
as a result you're able to contribute
back to that company bring a new
perspective but then also leave much
more i'd say broadly and like
you'll be able to fight the uh the curse
of kind of peripheral vision or
obfuscating peripheral vision
thank you thank you nade i think
all of these thoughts are i mean very
helpful so i mean that brings us to the
next question which is on behalf of the
community
so
uh
we
get to interact with a lot of
faculty in from different universities
and
they would want to maybe get involved in
a research which is more directed
towards the industry so the question
that we get is that how can we get it
level to an industrial grade research
and we do understand that there's like
there's a gap
but uh
when we think about a community so i
think there is a possibility to leverage
that community so
maybe shamir i can ask you in that
aspect of how do you think astrazeneca
as a company has looked into to address
this to utilize maybe a community or you
know under make them uh bridge this gap
sure yeah and then you know i can i can
also add uh a a quick point for the
previous question that you know the time
couplings were discussing so we're
always looking for talent we always have
uh internship co-op other types of
decisions you can always look into our
data science and ai career page and
apply directly and then also you can uh
you know
reach out to potential team members
including myself through linkedin or
twitter or whatever is your preferred
social media and you know we're always
looking for uh collaborations as well
and to coming back to the collaboration
specifically so we do have
both you know structured and you know
sort of at hope uh collaborative uh
engagement throughout uh you know uh
with with our community
uh research community here and that
means like for example we do collaborate
with cambridge mathematics program so we
we do research collaboration we have we
have co
sort of a co-founder of the cambridge
center for ai in medicine in the uk we
have collaborations with uh mila with
with the broad institutes several other
leading uh you know research
groups that we collaborate with and this
those are like sort of structured so
that's one fun approach that we're
taking and then also we have you know we
we strongly know that um we don't we
won't be able to solve all of the
problems that we have right like so we
do have what you call as a a platform
called causal like we need communities
in order to solve some of our grand
challenging uh problems actually and if
you can uh
you know look for astrazeneca causal
platform it's led by a friend
who leads the emerging innovation unit
and you can see a number of projects or
problems that are that we want we are
actually openly looking for
collaborators so that's a second
approach and the third one is you know
like like for example my group primarily
looking doing machine learning research
and we are always looking for
collaborators we know the problem is
these are some of the grand challenges
in the industry we need to work together
we're always looking for collaborators
so that's on a you know an individual
project level or an individual research
engagement level we can definitely think
about so as a structured program that is
cost solve and then also uh between uh
potentially interested research groups
can collaborate as well
so that's great to know anthony do you
have something for the i mean
researchers like faculty or early
researchers to collaborate on because
many times what we have heard from them
is that they they wanted to work on
exciting projects they have students but
the research idea is something that does
not align well or is not maybe properly
structured at times so maybe at an
industry level if that sort of help or
at least guidance is there that could
actually lead to some great outcomes
with whatever resources that they have
well thanks mohit i think you know it's
it's challenging to
to give you a coherent answer
in describing sort of point solutions i
think we're trying to look at this at
the macro scopic
level by trying to understand the
incentives of particular research
establishments um
uh what drives their interest and
focus in engaging uh
with a particular enterprise or what
their
research niche focus is and whether we
can match that with a particular
enterprise that's looking
at you know the gap in its own
capability to be filled with that
understanding and we're actually trying
to instantiate on our platform
mechanisms for matching to enable that
so that we understand the incentives of
the research establishments we
understand the incentives of the
enterprises and we can seek to match
um
you know uh that's a challenging
endeavor but it's already bearing fruit
because we're selling our software
application the e-data scientists into
large enterprises and they're asking us
to network data from research
establishments on the other side so the
beginning of this
ecosystem orchestration opportunity you
know we're seeing that now but i think
we're we're still come some significant
way from being able to you know
say to a particular researcher within a
particular
uh you know knowledge partner or
research establishment you know look
you're doing interesting work this
enterprise is interested in perhaps
collaborating with you i do see i do see
over the course of the next five to ten
years
the evolution of uh you know more clever
data orientated marketplace structures
where we do match uh research
establishments with enterprises because
that's that's that's necessary for the
acceleration of the science that we're
all involved in at the moment
thank you
so one question that i have especially
maybe if nahi we can answer that so we
heard about uh top institutions being
one of those places where the companies
look forward for innovation as well as
for students
so there are also uh we got to
work with a lot of
students from africa especially we have
a collaboration in nigeria and there are
other countries where students are there
who are equally capable
but they are not exposed to these
opportunities but the things have like
kind of changed with the covet
forward the silver lining that many
things are now online
and they get an opportunity so
do you have anything for
students like that who are coming from
maybe like so-called third world
countries where the education system is
not as structured or as good as other
countries comparatively
good science happens all over the world
you don't have to have a mit or an
oxford or cambridge or university of
toronto or berkeley logo next to your
resume
now
so that is a firm belief
secondly you know from our perspective
you will quickly suss out from the
company that you're applying to whether
or not they have that ethical alignment
look at the people on their website
um are they generally
building a company that is of
like-minded people to them or have
similar degrees from similar types of
institutions
or is it a little bit more diverse and
are they open to
you know that beliefs i i think
unfortunately i think a large percentage
of companies generally especially in
north america and many in europe will go
and hire from institutions that they
were trained at or that they know very
closely we've tried to push on that
belief
there are complexities in bringing on as
a canadian or a us or european company
bringing on co-ops or employees in other
countries
so there is a hurdle
that companies need to overcome
to justify bringing on a student whether
it be in nigeria or in rwanda or in the
philippines or in papua new guinea and
that's tax and you know employment law
and all these things and so how do you
convince the company that you are the
best person for this and for them to
make that investment
so that's you know from the
role of a individual applying to the
company now there's the role of the
company and what they need to do and i
continue to encourage companies
especially early stage that if it's not
us
that is go you know especially the
leaders in the industry if we're not
willing to think differently then it's
never going to happen so i spend a lot
of my time
globally outside of north america and
western societies and i've spent a lot
of time in
in asia in many of the emerging markets
i've spent a lot of time in africa you
know my family is east african kenyan
tanzania and i was at the next einstein
forum in kigali rwanda in 2018 and i got
to speak to
on behalf of the chancellor of the
university of rwanda
a professor at carnegie mellon and the
managing director of elsevier we got on
stage to speak with 2 000 stem students
at the university of rwanda to encourage
them to continue to pursue
their passions to help them think about
how to brand themselves to companies
that they may want to join that aren't
doing business in their country but then
also how do my rallying cry was how do
we as a
as companies that have the resources
available how do we continue to invest
in those students whether it be through
technology access
education
exposure or through internships or other
environments to bring them over so i i'd
say we're not nearly perfect
but it's worth the fight you know we
have as our director of
drug design platform team he was
educated in south africa right like
we have students that we've brought we
have students from india that we have
brought over to canada students from
china that we've brought in over from
china to study and to work at cyclica
now that mindset has to shift from a lot
of companies to enable more open
environments
but from a student perspective that's
not your business your businesses
continue to fight and differentiate
and if you want it just go tell a really
good story as to why that company should
choose you over somebody that's in their
own backyard
thank you i think that is a lot of
courage to all of the students here
now uh
maybe elia do you have something to add
you wanted to add something to this and
especially for the students in india no
no uh i was just clapping him and i
didn't want to raise his hand
i agreed with the point that naheed said
i won't take much time but yes i think
i'm in complete agreement uh with naheed
here on both the points um
the world is your oyster i think uh the
the
it does not matter these days if you are
bringing value it does not matter where
you're coming from
and the focus has to be on showcasing
how can you
you know uh
make that impact create that value for
the organization that you want to join
in so focus on that rather than uh so
you know again there are controllables
in life and then there are
uncontrollables
so wherever you've already studied it's
an uncontrollable now so let's not focus
there right
so i only want to focus on what i can
control what i can control is the next
steps and that is maximizing the value
that i can bring on the table just focus
on that don't even think where you're
coming from and then second is again in
agreement with naheed it also matters
what the philosophy of the company is
um if the company is someone they only
want to recruit from certain places
don't apply there i mean that's their
loss not your loss
so so so figure it out and and then go
for that opportunity that you think
you're capable of don't let the past or
don't let where you're from uh let you
discourage uh that's one thing i
definitely want to put on the table
so i i just want to jump in here and i
want to mention that
you know it's been really a pleasure to
hear all of your perspectives on these
important topics from all of our
participants
we want to ask you for just your final
remarks and we want to then move on to
the poster competition
but i do want to i just you know ask
everyone if you want to add you know a
minute or two of final remarks before we
move on thank you
i'll kick it off as i just want to add
one more comment to this important topic
that taren and i just covered
i'll give a quick example and then i'll
conclude
now more than ever especially in a
ongoing posts whatever you want to call
it covet environment what's become clear
to companies is that talent is global
and you're seeing not only talent but
venture capital institutions are funding
they used to fund in their own backyard
because why not and now they're saying
well let's go fund globally and
where capital goes and teams grow and
things are leveling off to an extent
where companies are looking to hide and
so now more than ever ramp up your
effort to go find those institutions
that it you're that admire or that that
you are most aligned with that you
admire that you are
scientifically passionate about
um i'll give a great example of a
student who approached cyclica
she's now on our machine learning team
she's been with us for two and a half
years but she came from cuba we had no
idea who this person was we had no idea
that cuba had a strong systems biology
and bioinformatics division
because we just weren't spending time
scouring the cuban market for talent
but this individual found a way
to somebody important within the cyclica
environment
built a relationship with this
individual and that individual opinion
said i think you need to take this
person seriously have a conversation
and within a few weeks we hired we went
through what in canada called the labor
market investment analysis we invested a
lot of time and capital out of our
pocket to bring this person over to cuba
and manage their entire visa application
whereby
we could have saved a lot of time and a
lot of effort to just go in our own
backyard because that individual was the
right person for us but how did they go
about it what they did not do was ping
me on linkedin
and say hey i'm interested in joining
cyclica can i have an interview because
i'm the last person that is going to
know what to do for a specific
contributor on a team so my
encouragement is linkedin is an
important tool and since sitting here 20
people have asked me to invite over
linkedin awesome i've accepted all of
you
but if you're interested in joining
cyclica understand what we're doing
understand who within the company is the
most important person to build a
relationship with build a relationship
with them it will take time and that's
the way you differentiate yourself
beyond just applying to a job on online
and so it takes effort it takes smart it
takes strategy and it takes the will to
allow the time to
come at you so if i'm going to conclude
my feedback to all of you is use the
resources that are available to you
as
a overall strategy build that strategy
and be smart about how you go about it
because it is possible and i can give
you dozens of examples of how we thought
about it but each one of those that
individual
came to us in a very unique way
thank you very much anthony do you have
any closing remarks
i think um
you know understand your why as an
individual why
are you doing what you're doing you know
what is your
what is your motivation what is your end
goal
uh
end goal in terms of what fulfills you
rather than you know a narrow short-term
research objective uh and then try and
match
your why with the why of the
organization you want to work with
um because
if you do that then you will you know
liberate your talents and you'll deliver
something to the enterprise you're
working with
i think uh you know
just echoing what naheed says
the covet pandemic has caused us that
eagle genomics to build a highly
distributed global business because
there was just no other way and uh
actually we've discovered that that's a
competitive advantage we're not going to
go back to the old we're not going to
consolidate back to the small
narrow
geographic focus we had previously so
there never has been a better time um
but do your homework i think the
panelists have said that before
understand your why and match it with
the why of the enterprise you're seeking
to work with and then i think
you know alchemy can be liberated with
that
okay thank you uh shamir would you like
to add something sure thank you uh so i
strongly believe uh you know
irrespective of all the advances that we
have right now whether it's in you know
within data machine intelligence
algorithms robotics we are still uh you
know
not close to that sort of a sort of a
dream of getting that right drug to
right patient
that would lead to you know an optimal
outcome and you know
at least side effect you know we are not
not yet there we are on a path towards
that
and we are all in this journey together
there are plenty of career opportunity
and the field is just you know getting
excited more exciting because we are now
moved from mono-ohmic dataset to
multi-omics and there is more to come
in
if you look at the biological aspects
behind this so it's a really exciting
field and and we need all hands on the
deck and that's that's what i want to
kind of put together as my my my last
comment
thank you and uh tyrone maybe you could
uh
somewhere i think uh
most of my
most of my panelists have already
covered the major points i'll just keep
it on the philosophical side where i
would say
keep that inquisitiveness quotient on i
mean often what makes the difference in
the longer run is asking that one
question
from someone who can help you
and more often that
i mean i have realized in my career is
that people are willing to help people
are willing to answer those questions
even if they look stupid to you
so
uh you know keep on learning um there is
no limit to that
uh beef up on that knowledge
and reach out to people where where you
face hurdles and you you never know who
can be your guardian angel and can help
you
so that is something that even naheed
said you know someone reached out to him
he took that call and and often you know
you'll you'll find uh walls as well but
uh you'll also find your guardian angels
so so just keep on doing that i'm happy
to you know answer more questions on
linkedin as well i'll post my linkedin
id i connect with people
wherever needed so happy to help where i
can
all right great thank you very much
everyone and thank you mohit for uh
moderating the panel would you like to
kind of summarize what we've heard so we
can transition away
yeah thank you so much i'm i mean we
have had a wonderful session with all of
you here thank you for your time and i
think we got to learn a lot from uh
student prospective from a researcher's
perspective from in general that what
are the steps that are required for us
to take the next and we also learn about
the internship opportunities that each
of the companies have to offer along
with other opportunities and skill sets
that you are looking forward to
so i think it was great uh for all of us
and i would like next uh
move to our uh much awaited poster
presentation session where students have
submitted a lot of uh they did a lot of
work and they shared their abstracts and
their posters
and
they presented with a video presentation
so i heard also that presentation skill
sets are kind of very important and how
do you articulate yourself to express
so the expression part and to do that we
encourage people to do video
presentations and we got a lot of those
which was just by a panel so now we will
just move to that and i would again like
to thank all of you
for being part of this and uh
now back to the presentations thank you
all right yes thank you very much
everyone for uh joining this panel for
sharing to all the panelists and the
speakers
uh we do have a poster presentation so
what we asked everyone to do we had over
100
students that have worked on research
projects over the past several months
and what we asked them to do is to
kind of find a question uh to ask
uh and uh thank you everyone from the
panel i really appreciate you joining
um and uh hope to continue this
conversation beyond the symposium
obviously
and
so what we want to
do now is uh kind of uh offer a
perspective from our industry sorry from
our research
judges
so
we had professor sona vasudevan from
georgetown university medical center uh
dr chris taylor
the director of the bioinformatics corps
at lbrn
dr philip campo from uh carnegie mellon
julia pannoth from haifa university
the associate director of the tower
bioinformatics research center
dr g pauliano chavez from university of
chicago
from amity university and dr harprika or
who is our research consultant in
omixlogic uh court uh curriculum
developer
uh to evaluate
all of the
submissions and i would like to ask
sonalika
to please go through
the scoring
and explain
again how was the scoring done
and help us understand who the top uh
posters were so nanika
thank you so much elia let me just
quickly share my screen
and tell what our judging criteria was
okay so this was the form that was given
out to our judges and the judges were as
explained by ilya so here we had a few
points on the basis of which the judges
have given the score to each and every
participant the first
was based on the introduction score and
then the methods and results how
perfectly were they explained and then
the discussion and the conclusion score
based on the discussions and the
presentation quality
and we had a poster presentation
submission page of each and every
participant where we had all the poster
submissions laid out let me just quickly
pull out the page and show it to all of
you as well
and based on that we have our
final winners
so we received a number of abstracts and
out of all of them we submitted print we
accepted 20 of them and we enlisted them
on our poster presentation submission
page which was with our judges since day
before yesterday and they were
evaluating it and we had the video
recordings and also the poster pdfs of
each and every poster let me just share
the link with you all as well to have a
glimpse of it thank you so much and uh
based on that we have our final winners
our first winner is kirak tank with a
score of 84 points our second winner is
dhruv mehra with a score of 82 points
and a third winner is andrew lee with a
score of 80 points though it was a very
close call the uh the difference was way
too less but yes so congratulations kira
tang drew mehra and andrew lee and
just to
make sure i'm not sure whether they are
present here or not but yes so we have
dhruv with us
uh
yeah first of all over to you would you
like to say a few words and then we can
uh have a word from our winners
yes so i wanted to mention that uh we
also have a special category called the
citizen science and uh that is related
to
everybody's scores not just the judges
and so the top uh
i'll just read out the top three uh but
i only the top one actually gets uh the
prize
so rude movie uh got 245 points out of
tayo uh 205 and then supan the day
i got 153 so a special mention for them
as well but uh rudely if you could
please add her she's a special category
for
um citizen science prize
and uh yeah would you like to pass it on
to them to share a few comments
thank you so much ilya congratulations
as well
uh drew i think you are here so could
you please take over the stage and say a
few words over to you dhruv
uh hello
i hope i'm audible
yes drove we are audible and also please
tell us something about your project
what you worked on
in a brief way maybe thank you
okay so uh
i hope i'm visible and audible uh first
of all i'll thank all the judges for
this
uh award especially
i'm talking about the project so i've
been working on this project since march
i believe
so i started my journey at pine biotech
in the march end itself and then you
know after the vigorous training i
started the project
so
uh talk about my interest so it
basically lies in the cancer research
and i'm more focused towards the
translational part so
uh
initially i started you know all the
literature review
and then uh i found this of the
esophageal carcinoma which is you know
quite
a dangerous type of carcinoma and it's
more prevalent in the
india itself and
there was an altruistic motivation
behind it like there were
quite a few my of my relatives who uh
passed away due to this type of cancer
so that was a motivation for me to
undertake this project and
then i started exploring and you know i
just saw it from a perspective of
precision medicine
which uh you know i'm pretty much
interested in and then i moved forward
and found
the results and i'm really happy to
present it in this poster conference
i'll especially thank my mentors uh
aliaser and
dr harpreed and dr muhit for this
opportunity
so
uh thanks a lot
thank you uh drew i wanted to ask uh i
know that kiera thing is not present but
jio is her uh mentor
geo would you like to
kind of speak on her behalf
okay so we have kira tang with us
okay great so maybe maybe yes hi kira
would you like to
um
say a few words
um sure
um hi everyone
i'm kira tang and
um i want to thank everyone for this
wonderful opportunity and thank
my mentor um debiano chavez but also um
this couldn't have happened without my
wonderful teammates
and
this was
um
based on the work that
we interns did
with um
dr chavez over the summer
and it was really an eye-opening
experience for all of us for me it was
my first
research project in bioinformatics and i
can't wait to see what the future holds
thank you so much kira and
congratulations once again now i would
like to
call on stage andrew lee i can see he's
online
uh i need to give the permissions for
you to speak right yep
hello
hi andrew
uh so first off thank you for the
opportunity to have this award
um i would like to thank all my mentors
at omnilogics of helped me
and also at my internship at columbia
university
so my project was on autism and finding
autism machines using machine learning
and that was my project i had worked on
over the summer which i had expanded
with the bioinformatics from the
fellowship program
thank you
thank you so much andrew
over to you ruthvi can you please tell
us something about your project and your
experience
and also how do you feel
we can see you routinely yeah i wasn't
able to unmute myself so hello everyone
and thank you so much for providing me
this platform and this award it means a
lot to me and for those who didn't know
this was my first bioinformatics project
so i initially started with fine biotech
aer black and i had zero knowledge of
bioinformatics stuff came a long way and
my hand mentors have pushed me a lot to
do this so this really means a lot to me
so thank you so much and thank you for
your constant guidance and support
thank you and maybe we could just ask
all of the mentors
and also all of the winners to turn on
their video
um so we have uh gipoliano chavez
uh we have mohit
mazumdar
thank you kira tang ruth vivaja
andrew lee
do we have mohit
okay
and so
i don't know if it is possible for you
somehow
sonalika to organize them so that
they're in the same place
yes so let me just first of all stop
sharing my screen
all of you please uh yes let me just put
them on spotlight as well let's have a
screen capture and capture this
beautiful moment
perfect
doctor mo and dr harpreet are you
available can you please if you're here
yes
okay it's
coming in a very beautiful way
thank you doctor
who's missing dr mohit is here ilya we
can see you
okay thank you perfect
all right thank you very much so i know
it's been a very long journey hard work
and so you really
deserve the prizes so uh together with
our sponsors we have a symbolic prize
which will include
so we have
uh you know you will have continuous
access to our platform we hope that you
do more with bioinformatics
you do have uh credits towards uh
programs in the next six months and 150
dollars in cash awards from our
collaborators
so we hope that you will use that money
wisely uh hopefully celebrate and buy
yourself something nice
so again thank you
we appreciate also all of the judges so
again i want to
say that you know this
has been
an experience
i'll just share my screen
again where
very established you know senior people
have reviewed your projects in detail um
many of them have seen you know hundreds
of projects and so i think it's a real
accomplishment that you were able to uh
receive this recognition uh professor
sona vasudevan dr chris taylor dr
phillip campell that miss uh julia
panoff uh dr japoliano chavez doctor of
bishops in gupta and dr jorpinka or um
you've heard their presentations over
the past couple of days hopefully and
you've seen kind of what they're all
about so i really appreciate you taking
the time to submit the projects
and uh we hope that you will again do
much more with bioinformatics in the
future and as we heard today there are
many opportunities to get involved
all right so thank you very much
everyone
and i will stop sharing
so in a conclusion right uh ruthvi just
uh let me
check once again
okay root v are you there
oh sorry not ruth
and
yeah okay so yeah i'll pass it on
okay
so to all the participants it was really
great to have you all with us and it was
amazing to have
such great speakers and the last panel
talk it was just fantastic like we got
so much of
knowledge motivation and inspiration
like words are less to tell what we felt
all of you might have felt that so also
i would like all the participants maybe
to just switch on their cameras if they
can and let's take some screen captures
and we'll be definitely we'll be back
with another beautiful symposium next
year thank you so much or just me
all the participants can you please
okay if you need time a minute or so to
comb your hair or style yourself you can
i'm just wondering how do i get all of
them on one screen like it's coming on
top
okay spotlight for everyone right india
do i need to do that
no i don't think you need to do it no
whoever's on video you can just hide
whoever's not on video
okay perfect spotlight anyone
okay thank you so much everyone
and also maybe you can just share your
experiences with us and we'll share
feedback forms and yeah the most
important thing the recordings of each
and every speaker of each and every talk
and yes some other much awaited and very
important question certification i'm
just getting questions on my personal
messages for certification
so those who had registered themselves
for the symposium your certificates
would be released by tomorrow and they
would be mailed to you so you will get
all your certificates on the mail and
also the recordings as well and also all
the details that were shared today about
the institutions each and everything and
uh don't forget to add our maid ids
marketing and the date fine dot bio to
your mail address because uh you might
skip it
if it's not added to your address book
and also i'm sharing are the main ids of
dr mohit mazumdar and our mentor dr
harpreet kaur
it was great to have you all here with
us
now i would like to pass it on to dr
mohit mazundar or maybe elia to give a
closing note
all right yes so again thank you very
much this was a great experience for all
of us and really appreciate all the work
that our team has put in uh all the
people that have the same background
like me have contributed
some of them don't have the background
but that's okay they also contributed
and so really appreciate the work that
you put in we know that it's been a very
long
long weekend nobody got any rest but
we are going to start the fall semester
soon
so in any case you weren't supposed to
rest um so hopefully uh you all
appreciated the uh speakers
the panelists i think we heard a lot of
uh very interesting uh comments uh and
uh perspectives on what's happening in
bioinformatics and so uh with that uh we
are going to plan a session where uh all
of the uh finalists and all of the uh
top projects are going to be able to
present their project in full we heard
today about the significance of
the actual presentation skills and your
ability to communicate your research
results so we're looking forward to that
session and during that session we are
going to also announce some of the
upcoming programs that we have starting
with the louisiana biomedical research
network with georgetown university with
other uh university partners that we
have so again thank you very much for
joining and we hope to stay in touch
with all of you
you can definitely connect with us as
selenica mentioned by email reaching out
to us and you all have the symposium
page that i think has all the
information
that you need to reach out to us so
again thank you for joining and uh
hopefully enjoy the rest of this
long weekend